A splash of fresh water will reach the depths of your heart. Those mighty blue waves can propel you forward or they can calm and soothe. Coast to Michigan coast. Simply feel the flow in the moment. And let those vast lakes, rivers and streams create everlasting memories. Jump right in and let fresh wash over you in Pure Michigan. Keep it fresh at Michigan.org. Or on our website.
清新的水花将触及你的心灵深处。那些浩荡的蓝色波浪可以推动你向前，也能带来平静与慰藉。从密歇根的这头到那头。只需感受当下流淌的思绪。让那些广袤的湖泊、河流和溪水创造永恒的记忆。纵身跃入，让清泉在纯净的密歇根涤荡你的身心。请访问 Michigan.org 保持新鲜感，或浏览我们的网站。
Valda Thomas didn't sleep well on the night of Tuesday, April 25, 1978. That evening, her husband Bill and his brother Rupert had returned from a day of foraging for mushrooms in the bush near Churro, a small South Australian township 90 kilometres northeast of the city of Adelaide. During their hunt, they had found something that Valda couldn't stop thinking about. Partially buried under some light scrub was what appeared to be the leg bone of a cow. Although the brothers noted it as strange, they carried on mushrooming without giving it too much thought. When Valda heard about the bone, she was rattled. The bushland surrounding Churro was dry and brittle and definitely wasn't suitable for cattle grazing.
1978年4月25日星期二晚上，瓦尔达·托马斯（Valda Thomas）没睡好觉。那天晚上，她的丈夫比尔（Bill）和他的兄弟鲁珀特（Rupert）从南澳大利亚州小镇楚罗（Truro）附近的灌木丛中 foraging（搜寻）蘑菇回来，楚罗位于阿德莱德市东北方90公里处。在搜寻过程中，他们发现了一些让瓦尔达挥之不去的东西。浅浅的灌木丛下半掩埋着疑似牛腿骨的东西。虽然兄弟俩觉得这很奇怪，但他们并没有多想，继续采蘑菇。当瓦尔达听到关于这块骨头的事时，她感到一阵恐慌。楚罗周边的灌木林干燥易碎，绝对不适合牛群放牧。
It was an inhospitable area for anything other than rabbits and native wildlife and Valda couldn't recall ever seeing cows during her previous visits out there. She went to bed thinking about the bone and when she finally drifted off into a restless sleep, a voice came to her in her dreams. It beckoned her to return to Churro, saying, come, come. Two days later, Valda urged Bill to take her to the spot where the bone was found. The husband and wife made the drive down the Sturt Highway,
除了兔子和本地野生动物之外，这是一个不适合任何生物生存的区域，瓦尔达记不清自己以前去那里时见过牛。她带着对这块骨头的想法上床睡觉，当她终于陷入不安的睡眠时，一个声音在她的梦中响起。它召唤她回到楚罗，说，来吧，来吧。两天后，瓦尔达敦促比尔带她去发现骨头的地方。这对夫妇沿着斯图尔特公路（Sturt Highway）驱车前行，
past rolling acres of agricultural land and sweeping plains until they reached Churro. With the population of only 800 residents, the wheat farming town didn't offer much for visitors. Passes by had little reason to stop in the area unless they needed a break between travelling to other destinations. Valda and Bill ventured onwards for 16 kilometers, eventually pulling off the highway and onto Swamp Road, a dirt stretch that led to rugged flood plains scattered with mally trees and native scrubs. They parked the car and Bill attempted to retrace the steps that he and Rupert had taken during their hunt for mushrooms. Finally, he found the spot. The leg bone was still there, partially hidden under some brittle branches.
驶过起伏的农田和广袤的平原，直到他们到达楚罗。这个小麦耕作小镇仅有800名居民，并没有给游客提供太多东西。路过的人几乎没有理由在这个地区停留，除非他们需要在前往其他目的地的旅途中休息一下。瓦尔达和比尔继续前行了16公里，最终驶离公路，拐上沼泽路（Swamp Road），这是一条通往点缀着马利树和本土灌木的崎岖洪泛区的泥土路。他们把车停下，比尔试图沿着他和鲁珀特寻找蘑菇时走过的足迹往回找。终于，找到了那个地方。那根腿骨还在，半掩在枯脆的树枝下。
This time, Bill and Valda drew closer to inspect it. They pulled it up, and to their horror, they discovered that on the other end of the bone was a woman's shoe. Inside were the remains of her painted toenails. The next day 18-year-old Veronica Knight had been looking forward to Christmas of 1976 for months. Not only did she enjoy the festive season, but this year was particularly special. Veronica had plans to visit some close friends in Melbourne who had recently welcomed their first baby. The trip was a big deal for Veronica.
这一次，比尔和瓦尔达走近去检查它。他们把它拉了起来，惊恐地发现骨头的另一端是一只女人的鞋。里面还残留着涂了指甲油的脚趾甲。第二天，18岁的维罗妮卡·奈特（Veronica Knight）已经盼望1976年的圣诞节好几个月了。她不仅喜欢节日季，而且今年的意义尤为特殊。维罗妮卡计划去墨尔本探望一些刚刚迎来第一个孩子的亲密朋友。这次旅行对维罗妮卡来说是一件大事。
Having been raised in the foster care system and spent most of her life in institutions, she didn't have any close family. Her mother passed away when she was just a baby, and her father was an alcoholic who felt unable to raise her on his own. It wasn't until Veronica was a teenager that she really began to feel part of the community. She moved into a boarding home for girls and became involved with a local Anglican church. It was there that she formed a close bond with a married couple named Peter and Jeanette Woods. Veronica spent many happy weekends with the Woods, staying at their house, helping with church duties, and baking in the kitchen with Jeanette. When the Woods announced they were relocating to Melbourne to have their first child, Veronica was crushed, but she also looked forward to being able to visit them in the big city.
由于在寄养系统中长大，大半生都在机构度过，她没有任何亲近的家人。她的母亲在她还是个婴儿时就去世了，父亲是个酗酒者，觉得自己无力独自抚养她。直到维罗妮卡十几岁时，她才真正开始感觉到自己是社区的一部分。她搬进了一家女孩寄宿家庭，并参与了当地的一所圣公会教堂。正是在那里，她与一对名叫彼得（Peter）和珍妮特·伍兹（Jeanette Woods）的夫妇建立了深厚的感情。维罗妮卡和伍兹夫妇度过了许多快乐的周末，住在他们家里，帮忙做教堂的工作，并和珍妮特一起在厨房里烘焙。当伍兹夫妇宣布他们要搬到墨尔本迎他们的第一个孩子时，维罗妮卡心碎了，但她也很期待能够去大城市看望他们。
She spent the next few months working part-time to save enough money to facilitate the journey. By December of 1976, Veronica had everything perfectly planned out. Her train ticket from Adelaide was booked for the evening of December 26, and the overnight journey would see her arriving in Melbourne the morning after. She would spend a week with Peter and Jeanette before returning to Adelaide on New Year's Eve. Veronica had a few purchases she needed to make first, so on the evening of December 23, she and her friend Jenny made their way into Rundlemore, a pedestrian shopping strip in the heart of Adelaide's CBD. The city was bustling with last-minute Christmas shoppers, and the girls browsed happily, soaking up the festive atmosphere.
在接下来的几个月里，她打零工攒够了钱来支付这次旅行的费用。到1976年12月，维罗妮卡已经把一切都完美地计划好了。她从阿德莱德出发的火车票预订在12月26日晚，经过一夜的行程，她将在第二天早晨抵达墨尔本。她将在彼得和珍妮特那里度过一周，然后在除夕夜返回阿德莱德。维罗妮卡有一些东西需要先买，所以在12月23日晚上，她和朋友珍妮（Jenny）来到了阿德莱德中央商务区中心的步行购物街朗德莫尔（Rundle Mall）。城市里挤满了最后关头采购圣诞节礼物的购物者，两个女孩开心地逛着，沉浸在节日的气氛中。
Veronica bought some new clothes and a present for the Woods' baby. After a few hours, Jenny noticed it was getting late. The girls had recently moved into a Salvation Army boarding house, which enforced a strict curfew of 11.30pm. They decided they'd better head to the bus stop to avoid getting in trouble. Along the way, they passed through the city cross-arcade and made a last-minute decision to have some photos taken in a black-and-white photo booth. Afterwards, they were almost at their bus stop on King William Road, one of the city's main thoroughfares, when Veronica stopped short. She realized she'd left one of her shopping bags in the photo booth. She told Jenny to go ahead without her and that she'd run back to grab her bags, then catch the next bus home.
维罗妮卡买了一些新衣服和送给伍兹夫妇孩子的礼物。几个小时后，珍妮注意到时间不早了。女孩们最近搬进了一家救世军寄宿公寓，那里实行晚上11点半的严格宵禁。她们决定最好去公交车站，以免惹上麻烦。一路上，她们穿过了城市十字长廊（city cross-arcade），并临时决定在一个黑白照相亭里拍几张照片。之后，她们快走到位于城市主要干道之一威廉国王路（King William Road）的公交车站时，维罗妮卡突然停下脚步。她意识到自己把其中一个购物袋忘在照相亭里了。她告诉珍妮先走，她要跑回去拿袋子，然后坐下一班车回家。
When Jenny arrived at the boarding house without Veronica, the house matron was immediately concerned. She waited up to make sure that Veronica got home safely, but as the minutes ticked by, there was no sign of her. By 1am, the matrons' worries peaked. She found Veronica's address book and phoned some of her friends to check if Veronica had perhaps stayed at one of their homes, but nobody had seen or heard from her. The next day, the matron filed a missing person report. The police didn't seem overly concerned. It was an unusual for young women to run away or go off with friends without telling anyone before reappearing unharmed a few days later. Those close to Veronica knew how excited she was about her trip to Melbourne and hoped that she'd simply show up as planned.
当珍妮没有维罗妮卡陪同抵达寄宿公寓时，宿管阿姨立刻担心起来。她熬夜等候以确保维罗妮卡安全到家，但随着分秒流逝，依然不见她的踪影。到了凌晨1点，宿管的担忧达到了顶点。她找到了维罗妮卡的通讯录，给她的几个朋友打电话，想确认维罗妮卡是否住在他们家，但没有人见过或听说过她。第二天，宿管报了人口失踪。警方似乎并不太担心。年轻女性离家出走或在不通知任何人的情况下与朋友外出，几天后又安然无恙地出现，这并不是什么稀奇事。那些与维罗妮卡亲近的人知道她对墨尔本之行有多兴奋，并希望她能像计划的那样出现。
On the morning of December 27, 1976, Peter Woods stood on the platform of Melbourne's Spencer Street station, waiting for the overland train from Adelaide to arrive. As he watched the passengers disembark, it became clear that Veronica wasn't among them. He called his wife Jeanette from a payphone and said, She didn't come. By the time Vowder and Bill Thomas discovered the human leg bone in the bushland surrounding Truro, Veronica Knight had been missing for 16 months. Given the opinion of police that she had run away, there hadn't been any searches for her, nor had her disappearance received any publicity. Police descended on the Truro area and searched a 600 meter radius from where the leg bone was found. They recovered the scattered remains of a young woman, along with a pair of jeans and a green cardigan.
1976年12月27日早晨，彼得·伍兹站在墨尔本斯潘塞街车站（Spencer Street station）的站台上，等待从阿德莱德开来的长途火车抵达。当他看着乘客下车时，很明显维罗妮卡并不在其中。他用公用电话打给妻子珍妮特说，她没有来。当瓦尔达和比尔·托马斯在特鲁罗（Truro）周边的灌木丛中发现人类腿骨时，维罗妮卡·奈特已经失踪16个月了。鉴于警方认为她离家出走的观点，没有任何人对她进行过搜索，她的失踪也没有受到任何公开报道。警方大举搜查了特鲁罗地区，并在发现腿骨方圆600米的范围内进行了搜寻。他们找回了一名年轻女性分散的遗骸，以及一条牛仔裤和一件绿色开衫。
It was Veronica Knight. Due to the skeletal state of Veronica's remains, there was nothing to indicate the cause of her death. The location near Swamp Road led investigators to deduce that Veronica had likely wandered into the bush in the summer heat without adequate supplies, where she became disoriented and died of dehydration. However, this explanation didn't entirely add up. Veronica had absolutely no reason to be in such an isolated place, and it seemed highly unlikely that she would have ventured so far given her upcoming trip to Melbourne she had been so looking forward to. Furthermore, the area of Adelaide where she was last seen was over an hour's drive from Truro, and she had no means of transport to get herself there. When Veronica went missing, she had been carrying a black purse with approximately $180 cash in it, a significant amount of money at the time, but the purse was nowhere to be seen. If she had simply gotten lost following a bush walk gone awry, surely the purse would still have been with her.
那是维罗妮卡·奈特。由于维罗妮卡的遗骸呈骨骼状态，没有任何迹象表明她的死因。沼泽路（Swamp Road）附近的位置让调查人员推断，维罗妮卡很可能在夏日的炎热中、在没有充足补给的情况下误入灌木丛，在那里迷失方向并脱水身亡。然而，这种解释并不能完全说得通。维罗妮卡绝对没有理由去这样一个偏僻的地方，鉴于她一直翘首以盼的即将到来的墨尔本之行，她冒险走得这么远似乎极不可能。此外，她最后一次被看到的阿德莱德地区距离特鲁罗有一个多小时的车程，而且她没有交通工具去那里。当维罗妮卡失踪时，她随身携带一个黑色钱包，里面大约有180现金，在当时是一笔相当可观的钱，但钱包却不知所踪。如果她只是在一次偏离路线的灌木丛散步后迷路了，钱包肯定还在她身上。
Investigators admitted that Veronica's death was suspicious, but with no evidence to suggest an alternative and no close family to fight for answers, her case was shelved. However, there was one investigator who wasn't prepared to accept that Veronica's death was a tragic accident. Detective Sergeant Bob Giles had been working in the missing persons division of the South Australian Police, and had noticed a strange pattern emerge. During the seven-week timeframe between Christmas of 1976 and early February of 1977, three young women had gone missing from the city centre after waiting for a bus. Four others had gone missing from the vicinity of a bus stop or main road on the city's outskirts. No witnesses had seen anything untoward, and each woman had therefore been marked by the police as voluntarily absent. Partly because of this, news of their disappearances had never been made public. Detective Giles wasn't buying it.
调查人员承认维罗妮卡的死因可疑，但由于没有证据表明有其他可能，也没有亲近的家人为寻求答案而奔走，她的案件被搁置了。然而，有一位调查人员并不准备接受维罗妮卡的死是一场悲惨事故的说法。侦探警长鲍勃·吉尔斯（Bob Giles）一直在南澳大利亚警察局的失踪人口科工作，并注意到了一种奇怪的模式出现。在1976年圣诞节到1977年2月初之间的七周时间里，有三名年轻女性在等完公交车后从市中心失踪。另有四人从城市郊区的公交车站或主要道路附近失踪。没有目击者看到任何异常情况，因此每位女性都被警方登记为自行离去。部分由于这一点，她们失踪的消息从未公之于众。吉尔斯侦探并不买账。
Although none of the missing women were personally connected in any way, he believed there were simply too many similarities between each case for the disappearances to be coincidental. These weren't vulnerable women living on the outskirts of society. Each missing woman came from good homes and had loved ones who were expecting them. They had all disappeared without making further contact or collecting any of their belongings. Although some of them had run off in the past, to Detective Giles, they didn't seem like typical runaways. His theory was far more serious. He believed that a serial killer was at play. South Australia in the 1970s was considered a relatively safe place.
尽管失踪的女性之间没有任何个人联系，但他认为每个案件之间的相似之处实在太多，不可能是巧合。这些并不是生活在社会边缘的弱势女性。每个失踪的女性都来自良好的家庭，并且都有爱她们、期盼她们归来的人。她们都在没有进一步联系或拿走任何个人物品的情况下消失了。尽管其中一些人过去曾离家出走过，但在吉尔斯侦探看来，她们并不像典型的离家出走者。他的理论要严重得多。他认为有一个连环杀手在作案。20世纪70年代的南澳大利亚被认为是一个相对安全的地方。
The most notorious crimes related to children, including the mysterious disappearance of siblings Jane, Anna and Grant Beaumont as covered in episode 100 of Casefile, and the suspected abduction of Joanne Ratcliffe and Kirsty Gordon as covered in episode 163 of Casefile. Serial killings were unheard of, and most murders were committed by someone known to the victim. Therefore, Detective Giles's theory that a serial killer had been operating in Adelaide during the summer of 76 and 77 was extreme. Nonetheless, he presented his findings to the officer in charge of the major crime squad, who was flawed by the revelation. He agreed that the seven disappearances were likely the cause of a serial offender and immediately appointed an investigative team to launch a full inquiry. The investigative team knew the only way to bring attention to the pattern of missing women was for one of their loved ones to speak out. If they could raise public awareness, someone might come forward with information that could lead to their whereabouts.
最臭名昭著的罪行与儿童有关，包括简、安娜和格兰特·博蒙特兄妹的神秘失踪（如《罪案实录》第100集所述），以及乔安妮·拉特克利夫和柯丝蒂·戈登的疑似绑架案（如《罪案实录》第163集所述）。连环杀人案闻所未闻，大多数谋杀案都是由受害者认识的人犯下的。因此，吉尔斯侦探关于连环杀手在76年和77年夏季在阿德莱德作案的理论是极其激进的。尽管如此，他还是将调查结果呈报给了重案组负责人，后者被这一发现震惊了。他同意这七起失踪事件很可能是由一名连环罪犯造成的，并立即指派了一个调查小组展开全面调查。调查小组知道，要让人们关注失踪女性的模式，唯一的办法就是让她们的至亲大声发声。如果他们能提高公众意识，可能会有人提供能解开她们下落的信息。
However, many parents of the missing women were reluctant to speak publicly about their daughters. Some families wanted to avoid potential criticism, while others viewed their child's disappearance as a private issue. Detective Giles approached one of the only families he thought might be willing to help. 16-year-old Julie Makita was a trustworthy and sensible teenager, so when she phoned her parents at 9.30pm on the evening of January 21, 1977 and asked if she could stay out a little later, they didn't hesitate to give their permission. Julie's father told her to be home by 11, and she happily agreed. It was the summer holidays, and she was enjoying the youthful sense of freedom. Julie and her best friend Camilla had spent the day selling jewellery at a small street side stand in the city, each earning $10 for their efforts. When they closed up shop for the day, Camilla went home, while Julie and an acquaintance named Max returned the unsolved inventory to its owner in the Adelaide Central Market.
然而，许多失踪女性的父母都不愿公开谈论他们的女儿。一些家庭希望避免潜在的批评，而另一些家庭则将孩子的失踪视为私事。吉尔斯侦探找到了他认为可能愿意帮忙的唯一家庭之一。16岁的朱莉·马基塔（Julie Makita）是一个值得信赖且懂事的青少年，因此当她在1977年1月21日晚上9点30分给父母打电话询问是否可以晚点回家时，他们毫不犹豫地同意了。朱莉的父亲告诉她11点前回家，她高兴地答应了。那是暑假，她正在享受那种青春期的自由感。朱莉和她最好的朋友卡米拉（Camilla）白天在城市的一个小型街边摊位上卖珠宝，每人赚了10美元。当她们结束一天的生意时，卡米拉回家了，而朱莉和一个名叫马克斯（Max）的熟人将未卖出的库存归还给了阿德莱德中央市场的业主。
Julie and Max then went to the Majestic Hotel on King William Street to play a few rounds of pool. The pub was right near the bus stop that would take her home to the inner eastern suburb of St. Peter's. 11pm came and went, and Julie didn't return home. Her parents, Irush and Anne-Marie, hoped she had simply stayed at a friend's house and forgotten to call, but when she still didn't make contact the next day, they became worried sick. They tracked Max down to see if he knew where Julie could be. Max said that after playing pool, he walked Julie to her bus stop on King William Street at around 10.30pm. As he walked away, he saw a white car pull up to the curb and call out to Julie. Julie approached the vehicle as though she knew the occupants.
朱莉和马克斯随后去了威廉国王街的雄伟酒店（Majestic Hotel）打了几局台球。这家酒吧就在公交车站附近，可以带她回内东郊的圣彼得斯（St. Peter's）。晚上11点到了又过去，朱莉没有回家。她的父母伊鲁什（Irush）和安娜-玛丽（Anne-Marie）希望她只是住在朋友家里，忘了打电话，但第二天她依然没有联系他们，这让他们急得像热锅上的蚂蚁。他们找到了马克斯，看他是否知道朱莉可能在哪里。马克斯说，打完台球后，他在晚上10点半左右把朱莉送到了威廉国王街的公交车站。当他走开时，他看到一辆白色的汽车停在路边，并向朱莉喊话。朱莉像认识车上的人一样向车走去。
A man got out of the car, and Julie climbed into the middle of the front seat. The Makitas reported Julie's disappearance to the police, who mostly brushed it off as typical teenage antics, and assured the worried parents that their daughter would likely show up soon. Irush and Anne-Marie were convinced that Julie wasn't the kind of teenager who would run off with friends without letting them know. She was a good daughter and a student who planned on becoming a doctor. Maybe she had gotten into an accident or been injured and was unable to get in touch. Still, they had their doubts. Desperate for answers, Anne-Marie turned to Julie's journal and some letters she had written to her older sister who lived interstate. She discovered that perhaps she didn't know her daughter as well as she thought.
一个男人从车里出来，朱莉爬上了前排座椅中间。马基塔夫妇向警方报案朱莉失踪，警方大多将其斥为典型的青少年恶作剧，并向焦虑的父母保证女儿很可能会很快出现。伊鲁什和安娜-玛丽坚信朱莉不是那种不打招呼就和朋友跑掉的青少年。她是一个好女儿，是一个立志成为医生的学生。也许她出了事故或受伤了，无法取得联系。尽管如此，他们还是心存疑虑。渴望得到答案的安娜-玛丽翻看了朱莉的日记以及她写给她住在外州的姐姐的一些信件。她发现，或许她并不像自己想象的那样了解女儿。
Julie wrote of partaking in risky behavior, such as hitchhiking. Anne-Marie was shocked. She questioned whether Julie had perhaps made the ill-informed decision to take off on an adventure after all, or perhaps join a commune. In hindsight, the last conversation Anne-Marie had with her daughter had been a strange one. Julie had asked about her mother's younger years and then said, We were very happy when we were children, my sister and I. Thank you for my childhood, mother. I just wanted you to know that. Anne-Marie wasn't sure whether to interpret that as Julie's subtle way of saying goodbye.
朱莉在日记中写到参与搭便车等危险行为。安娜-玛丽大吃一惊。她质疑朱莉是否最终做出了不明智的决定，去进行一场冒险，或者加入一个公社。事后回想起来，安娜-玛丽与女儿的最后一次对话是一个奇怪的对话。朱莉问起母亲年轻时的岁月，然后说，我们做孩子的时候非常快乐，我和我姐姐。谢谢你给我一个童年，妈妈。我只是想让你知道这一点。安娜-玛丽不确定是否应该将其解读为朱莉委婉的告别方式。
Adding to her doubts was a poem she had found that Julie had written. It read, The day is done. All that could pass, past. All that could live, lived. All that is, was. All that was now, is then. The day is done. Julie had been missing for nearly two years when Detective Giles approached the Makita family with his theory that Julie and several other young women had fallen victim to foul play at the hands of a serial offender. Anne-Marie didn't know what to think. She had tried her hardest not to let her mind go to a dark place and now she was being forced to confront her worst fears head on. She and Irush agreed to front the media to raise awareness about the pattern of missing women in the hopes that would encourage someone with information to come forward. If nothing else, they hoped that sharing their story might persuade other teenage girls to be more careful when accepting rides from strangers. Anne-Marie said that Julie was a fastidious child. If someone had offered her a lift and tried to force himself on her, she would have fought back. Perhaps that had led the offender to kill her out of panic and then hide her body somewhere. Irush said the hardest thing about Julie's disappearance was not knowing the truth. He likened it to being on an emotional seesaw that was tearing the family apart.
加深她疑虑的是她发现的一首朱莉写的诗。上面写着，白昼已逝。一切能过去的，都过去了。一切能活过的，都活过了。一切存在的，都曾存在。一切曾是的，如今皆是。白昼已逝。当吉尔斯侦探带着他的理论接近马基塔家族时，朱莉已经失踪近两年了，他认为朱莉和其他几位年轻女性落入了连环罪犯的毒手。安娜-玛丽不知该作何感想。她曾竭尽全力不让自己的思绪陷入黑暗，而现在她被迫直面自己最恐惧的噩梦。她和伊鲁什同意出面面对媒体，以提高人们对失踪女性模式的认识，希望这能鼓励知情者挺身而出。退一步讲，他们希望分享他们的故事能够劝说其他少女在接受陌生人搭车时更加小心。安娜-玛丽说，朱莉是一个严谨的孩子。如果有人主动提供搭便车并试图对她施暴，她一定会反抗。也许这导致罪犯出于惊慌而杀害了她，然后把她的尸体藏在某个地方。伊鲁什说，朱莉失踪最痛苦的是不知道真相。他将其比作坐在一个正在撕裂这个家庭的情感跷跷板上。
The Makita's story made local headlines, with reporters drawing a connection to other young women who had gone missing around the same time. But nobody came forward with information that shed light on any of the girls' whereabouts. A few weeks later, on April 15, 1979, a police officer was patrolling the Sturt Highway on his motorcycle. It was the Easter Long Weekend, a notoriously dangerous time on the northern roads as motorists flocked from the city to holiday on the nearby York Peninsula and in the Barossa Valley wine region. The officer was on the lookout for any reckless behavior when he was suddenly flagged down by a group of four young men. They'd been out hunting rabbits in the bush near Truro and had found something disturbing. They handed the item to the police officer wrapped in a sheet of plastic. It was a human skull. The youths directed police to the paddock where they had made the discovery. It was down Swamp Road, just 50 meters from the fence line. For investigators, this location immediately raised red flags. The location was less than two kilometers from where Veronica Knight's remains had been found by Bill and Valda Thomas a year earlier. The chances that two people had innocently lost their lives out in this remote area seemed incredibly unlikely.
马基塔一家的故事成了当地的头条新闻，记者们将之与同期失踪的其他年轻女性联系起来。但没有人提供能阐明这些女孩下落的信息。几周后的1979年4月15日，一名警察正骑着摩托车在斯图尔特公路上巡逻。那是复活节长周末，由于驾车者从城市涌向附近的约克半岛（York Peninsula）和巴罗萨山谷（Barossa Valley）葡萄酒产区度假，北方道路上这段时间历来非常危险。这名警察正在寻找任何鲁莽行为，突然被四名年轻男子拦了下来。他们在特鲁罗附近的灌木丛中猎兔时，发现了一些令人不安的东西。他们把用塑料布包着的东西交给了警察。那是一个人类头点头骨。这群年轻人引导警察来到他们发现头骨的牧场。那是沿着沼泽路，距离篱笆线仅50米。对调查人员来说，这个地点立即敲响了警钟。这个地点距离比尔和瓦尔达·托马斯一年前发现维罗妮卡·奈特遗骸的地方不到两公里。两个人无辜地在这个偏远地区丧生的几率似乎微乎其微。
A full-scale search of the area was ordered and it wasn't long before several more human bones were recovered as well as a pair of women's underwear and a small purse. When news of the discovery hit the media, many anticipated that the body would be identified as Julie Makeda. Married couple Andreas and Margarita Pittman were sitting down to watch the evening news in their home in Taperoo, a suburb 18 kilometers northwest of Adelaide. The house had felt quiet ever since their 16-year-old daughter Sylvia Pittman had vanished just over two years prior. Sylvia had dreams of becoming a model and not wanting to rely on her good looks alone, she had secured a job in a retail boutique in order to learn more about the fashion industry. On Sunday, February 6, 1977, she walked from her home in Taperoo to catch the bus to work on nearby Military Road and was never seen again. When Sylvia failed to return home that night, her parents were immediately worried but weren't sure what to think. Not long before her disappearance, Sylvia had run off to Melbourne where she'd ultimately been placed in a women's detention centre.
当局下令对该地区进行全面搜查，不久之后，又找回了几块人类骨头以及一双女性内衣和一个小钱包。当发现的消息登上媒体头条时，许多人预计这具尸体将被辨认为朱莉·马基塔。已婚夫妇安德烈亚斯（Andreas）和玛格丽塔·皮特曼（Margarita Pittman）正坐在阿德莱德西北18公里处的郊区塔佩罗（Taperoo）的家中看晚间新闻。自从他们16岁的女儿西尔维亚·皮特曼（Sylvia Pittman）两年多前神秘失踪以来，家里一直感到很安静。西尔维亚梦想成为一名模特，并且不想仅仅依仗自己的美貌，她在一家零售精品店找到了一份工作，以便更多地了解时尚产业。1977年2月6日星期日，她从塔佩罗的家中步行去乘公交车，到附近军事路（Military Road）上的工作地点上班，就再也没有露面。当西尔维亚那天晚上没有回家时，她的父母立刻担心起来，但又不知该作何感想。就在她失踪前不久，西尔维亚曾离家出走去墨尔本，最终被安置在女子拘留中心。
The whole experience had frightened her and she vowed to her parents that she'd never run away again. To avoid a recurrence, Andreas and Margarita had made an effort to give Sylvia more freedom and they didn't think she'd betray their trust for a second time. They had filed a missing person report but remained uncertain as to whether Sylvia had gone off on her own accord or fallen victim to foul play. Now watching the news, they saw that skeletal remains of an unidentified female had been found in a paddock near Truro for the second time in almost a year. An item of jewellery had also been recovered, a 14 carat gold necklace featuring a medallion of a guardian angel. Andreas and Margarita's hearts sank. There was no question that the necklace belonged to Sylvia. It had been given to her by her Austrian grandmother and she treasured it dearly. The Pittman's contacted police who used the dental records to confirm that the second body found near Truro was indeed that of Sylvia Pittman.
这段经历吓坏了她，她向父母发誓绝不再离家出走。为了避免重蹈覆辙，安德烈亚斯和玛格丽塔努力给西尔维亚更多的自由，他们不认为她会第二次辜负他们的信任。他们报了人口失踪案，但仍然不确定西尔维亚是自愿出走还是成了暴力犯罪的受害者。现在看着新闻，他们看到在特鲁罗附近的牧场上，近一年来第二次发现了未识别女性的骨骼残骸。还找回了一件首饰，一条14K金项链，上面挂着一个守护天使的奖章。安德烈亚斯和玛格丽塔的心沉了下去。毫无疑问，这条项链属于西尔维亚。那是她奥地利祖母送给她的，她非常珍视。皮特曼夫妇联系了警方，警方利用牙科记录确认特鲁罗附近发现的第二具尸体确实是西尔维亚·皮特曼。
Any remaining doubts the police may have had were immediately quashed. It was now clear they were dealing with a serial killer. A search party was quickly amassed and 85 police officers and cadets set up camp in the bushland surrounding Truro. With a designated search area of 20 square kilometres, they worked around the clock, sleeping in tents and makeshift bunks inside horse floats. Cadets crawled through the rugged terrain on hands and knees while officers covered the area on horseback and motorcycle. They persevered through unseasonable heat and light rain, convinced that more discoveries were imminent. Foraging near the base of a tree near where Veronica's body was found, police came across a woman's shoe. It matched the description of one that was worn by another young woman who had gone missing around the same time as Veronica and Sylvia. Police had their suspicions as to who the shoe belonged to but awaited the discovery of any remains before making an announcement.
警方可能存有的任何剩余疑虑立即被消除了。现在很清楚，他们正在应对一个连环杀手。搜救队迅速集结，85名警察和学员在特鲁罗周边的灌木丛中搭建了营地。划定的搜索面积达20平方公里，他们夜以继日地工作，睡在帐篷和马匹拖车内的简易床铺上。学员们手脚并用地爬过崎岖的地形，而警官们则骑着马匹和摩托车巡视该地区。他们顶住了反常的高温和小雨，坚信会有更多的发现。在靠近维罗妮卡尸体发现地的一棵树根附近搜寻时，警察偶然发现了一只女鞋。它与另一名年轻女性穿的一只鞋的描述相符，该女子在维罗妮卡和西尔维亚失踪前后失踪。警方对这只鞋属于谁心存怀疑，但在宣布之前等待任何遗骸的发现。
Then, on April 26, 1979, a team of mounted police carefully led their horses over a barbed wire fence bordering Swamp Road. They foraged around and spotted something under a large branch. It was a shallow grave. Crudely covered by light bush was the skeleton of 15-year-old Connie Yordanides. Connie had been having some ongoing conflict at home. The teenager sought a level of freedom that her strict Greek parents didn't allow and in turn they constantly butted heads. Following the advice of some school friends, Connie reached out to the Department of Community Welfare and lodged a complaint against her parents. She was temporarily placed in a foster home before the Department negotiated some conditions for her return to the family home. Connie's parents reluctantly agreed with the Department's recommendation that they should let her come and go from the house as she pleased.
然后，在1979年4月26日，一队骑警小心翼翼地引导着他们的马匹越过沼泽路旁边的带刺铁丝网篱笆。他们在四处搜寻时，在大树枝下发现了一些东西。那是一个浅浅的坟墓。粗糙地被浅矮树丛覆盖着的是15岁女孩康妮·约达尼季斯（Connie Yordanides）的骨骼。康妮家里最近一直有一些持续的冲突。这个十几岁的女孩追求一种她严厉的希腊父母不允许的自由度，因此他们经常顶撞。在一些学校朋友的建议下，康妮联系了社区福利部，并对父母提出了投诉。在部门协商她返回家庭的一些条件之前，她被暂时安置在一个寄宿家庭中。康妮的父母不情愿地同意了福利部的建议，即应该让她随心所欲地进出家门。
It pained them to do so but they were just happy to have their daughter back home. At around 6pm on February 9, 1977, Connie had told her parents she was going to her boyfriend's house and then to a drive-in movie. Her boyfriend lived one kilometer from her home in the western suburb of Brooklyn Park and Connie planned to walk there. Her father offered to drive her but Connie declined. When she failed to return home that night, her parents thought she had simply run away. They made inquiries with Connie's friends and contacted the Department of Community Welfare to voice their concerns but four days passed before they reported Connie's disappearance to the police. Detective Sergeant Bob Giles had come across Connie's missing person file when piecing together the pattern of mysterious disappearances during the summer of 1977 and was convinced that she had fallen victim to foul play. Investigators came to the conclusion she may have lied to her parents about going to the drive-in and had instead headed into the city where she crossed paths with the killer.
这样做让他们感到痛苦，但只要女儿能回家，他们就很高兴了。1977年2月9日晚上6点左右，康妮告诉父母她要去男朋友家，然后去看汽车电影院。她的男朋友住在西部郊区布鲁克林公园（Brooklyn Park）她家一公里外的地方，康妮计划步行去那里。她父亲提出开车送她，但康妮拒绝了。当她那天晚上没有回家时，她的父母以为她只是离家出走了。他们向康妮的朋友们打听，并联系社区福利部表达他们的担忧，但过了四天他们才向警方报告康妮失踪。侦探警长鲍勃·吉尔斯在拼凑1977年夏天神秘失踪案的模式时，偶然遇到了康妮的失踪档案，并坚信她成了暴力犯罪的受害者。调查人员得出结论，她可能对父母撒谎说要去汽车电影院，而是去了市中心，在那里她与凶手狭路相逢。
When the third body found near Truro was confirmed to be Connie, her father Yordana partly blamed the Department of Community Welfare for his daughter's death. Had they not interfered with his family business, Yordana said he never would have let Connie go out on her own the night she vanished. He told reporters, I strongly believe it and that's what counts at the moment. Just 100 meters from where Connie's body was found, the same team of mounted police came across the remains of another young woman. Her platform sandal still perfectly intact. The victim was slightly older than the others, giving police an indication as to who it might be. 26-year-old Vicki May Howe worked as a nurse's aide. She was a divorced mother of three who lived with her boyfriend Harry in the western suburb of Corralta Park. At around 7pm on February 9, 1977, Vicki was washing the dishes after dinner when she overheard a conversation between Harry and his brother. She thought they were talking about her and became upset.
当特鲁罗附近发现的第三具尸体被确认是康妮时，她的父亲约尔达纳（Yordana）部分将女儿的死归咎于社区福利部。约尔达纳说，如果他们没有干涉他的家庭事务，他绝不会让康妮在她失踪的那天晚上独自外出。他告诉记者，我坚信这一点，这才是目前最重要的。就在发现康妮尸体100米远的地方，同一支骑警队偶然发现了另一名年轻女性的遗骸。她的厚底凉鞋仍然完好无损。受害者比其他人稍大一些，给警方提供了一个线索，让他们知道她可能是谁。26岁的维琪·梅·豪（Vicki May Howe）是一名护士助理。她是一位育有三个孩子的离异母亲，与男友哈里（Harry）住在西部郊区的科拉尔塔公园（Corralta Park）。1977年2月9日晚上7点左右，维琪在晚饭后洗碗时，无意中听到哈里和他兄弟的对话。她以为他们在谈论她，因而感到心烦意乱。
Vicki told Harry she was going outside to get some clothes off the line, but instead she walked outside onto Anzac Highway, a main thoroughfare connecting Adelaide CBD with Glenelg Beach. She was last seen waiting for a city-bound bus. Vicki had run off in the past, so Harry didn't think too much of it at first and was convinced she'd come home eventually. When Vicki still hadn't returned four days later, Harry told Vicki's sister, who reported her as missing. Detectives had an identified Vicki as one of the potential victims of the Truro serial killer. She was older than the others and didn't quite fit the same profile. However, after forensic investigators examined the fourth body found in the bush, there was no doubt that it was Vicki Howe. In addition to Julie Makeda, there were still two more women who the task force believed had fallen victim to the same fate. 15-year-old Tanya Kenny was a bright student who naturally excelled at school, but despite her academic achievements, she often clashed with her parents.
维琪告诉哈里她要出去把晾衣绳上的衣服收进来，但她却走到了安扎克公路（Anzac Highway）上，这是一条连接阿德莱德中央商务区与格雷尔格海滩（Glenelg Beach）的主要干道。她最后一次被看到是在等一辆开往市中心的公交车。维琪过去曾离家出走过，所以哈里起初并没有多想，并坚信她最终会回家。当四天后维琪依然没有回来时，哈里告诉了维琪的姐姐，后者报了人口失踪。侦探们已将维琪确定为特鲁罗连环杀手的潜在受害者之一。她比其他人年长，不太符合相同的档案。然而，在法医调查人员检查了在灌木丛中发现的第四具尸体后，毫无疑问这就是维琪·豪。除了朱莉·马基塔，专案组还认为有两名女性落入了同样的命运。15岁的塔尼娅·肯尼（Tanya Kenny）是一个聪明的学生，在学校里自然表现优异，但尽管她学业优异，她却经常与父母发生冲突。
Tanya desired a level of freedom that her parents wouldn't allow, and this led to some ongoing problems. On December 31, 1976, Tanya had asked her parents if she could attend a New Year's Eve party at the Cliton Rock Surf Life Saving Club in Haberah, a coastal town 80km south of Adelaide. Her parents said no, but Tanya went anyway. She spent New Year's Day there too, before leaving to catch a bus back to Adelaide on January 2, 1977. Nobody had seen or heard from Tanya since, and her parents expressly forbid the police from seeking any publicity about her disappearance. The seventh and final woman that police believed could be a victim of the Truro serial killer was 20-year-old Deborah Lamb. Deborah was considered a loner who could be a little naive. In mid-1976, she gave birth to a daughter she felt she was unable to care for and had given up for adoption at six months old.
塔尼娅渴望父母不允许的自由度，这导致了一些持续的问题。1976年12月31日，塔尼娅问父母她是否可以参加位于哈贝拉（Haberah）的克利夫顿洛克冲浪救生俱乐部（Cliton Rock Surf Life Saving Club）的除夕派对，这是一个距离阿德莱德以南80公里的沿海小镇。她的父母说不行，但塔尼娅还是去了。她也在那里度过了元旦，然后于1977年1月2日离开，搭乘公交车返回阿德莱德。自那以后，没有人见过或听说过塔尼娅，她的父母明确禁止警方就她的失踪寻求任何公开报道。警方认为可能是特鲁罗连环杀手受害者的第七个也是最后一个女性是20岁的黛博拉·兰姆（Deborah Lamb）。黛博拉被认为是一个有点天真的独行侠。1976年中期，她生下一个女儿，觉得自己无力抚养，并在六个月大时将其送养。
By February 12, 1977, Deborah was living in a caravan park in the north-eastern suburb of Windsor Gardens. At around 6pm, she boarded a bus into the city for a night out and never returned. Deborah hadn't spoken to her family for five months, but she was noticed to be missing when she failed to claim her unemployment benefits, or pick up some items of clothing that she had waiting for her at a church drop-in centre. Her bank account also hadn't been touched since the night of her disappearance. Investigators were convinced that the bodies of Julie Makeda, Tanya Kenney and Deborah Lamb were amongst those dumped in the bushland surrounding Truro, and the search for their remains continued for days. However, no further discoveries were made, and the search camp eventually disbanded,
到1977年2月12日，黛博拉住在东北郊温莎花园（Windsor Gardens）的一个房车公园里。晚上6点左右，她登上一辆去市里过夜的公交车，再也没有回来。黛博拉已经五个月没有和家人说话了，但当她未能领取失业救济金，或者没有去教会收容中心取她等候在那里的几件衣物时，人们注意到她失踪了。自她失踪的那天晚上起，她的银行账户也一直没有动过。调查人员确信朱莉·马基塔、塔尼娅·肯尼和黛博拉·兰姆的尸体就在被倾倒在特鲁罗周围灌木丛中的尸体之列，对她们遗骸的搜寻持续了数天。然而，没有更多的发现，搜寻营地最终解散了，
with investigators instead turning their focus on catching the killer. The case quickly made national headlines, with the area described as a, quote, graveyard of missing girls. Members of the small Truro community were outraged that their quiet, safe town had become associated with such a grisly murder investigation. They firmly believed the killer wasn't from the area. If he was a local, he would know about the nearby mineshafts and would have dumped the bodies there instead, where they'd likely never be found. The community also resented the name of their town being tied to the crimes.
调查人员转而将重点放在抓捕凶手上。该案迅速登上全国头条，该地区被描述为一个引号中的“失踪女孩墓地”。小镇特鲁罗的居民对他们安静、安全的城镇与如此可怕的谋杀案调查产生联系感到愤怒。他们坚信凶手不是本地人。如果他是本地人，他会知道附近的矿井，并会把尸体倒在那里，在那里它们很可能永远不会被找到。社区还对他们城镇的名字与这些罪行联系在一起感到不满。
There were other townships closer to the dumping ground, but the media felt that Truro was more recognisable to the greater public. While the people of Truro agonised, residents of Adelaide seemed oddly indifferent. Despite there being four confirmed murder victims and three more missing women suspected of having fallen to the same fate, there was an astonishing lack of public outrage. The only witness to any of the alleged abductions had been Julie Makeda's friend Max, who had seen a man in a white car approach Julie on the night that she vanished. Partly because of this, people seemed to accept that the young women had likely accepted a lift with a stranger and therefore only had themselves to blame.
还有其他距离抛尸地点更近的小镇，但媒体认为特鲁罗对广大公众来说更容易辨认。当特鲁罗的人民痛苦煎熬时，阿德莱德的居民似乎表现得奇怪地冷漠。尽管有四名确诊的谋杀受害者和另外三名涉嫌遭遇相同命运的失踪女性，但公众的愤怒却惊人地缺乏。任何所谓绑架事件的唯一目击者是朱莉·马基塔的朋友马克斯，他在朱莉失踪的那天晚上看到一个开着白车的人接近朱莉。部分由于这一点，人们似乎接受了这些年轻女性可能接受了陌生人的搭便车，因此只能怪她们自己。
One journalist noted, Outrage and a hue and cry for the killer are noticeably absent. An article in the Sydney Morning Herald read, Adelaide seems to have accepted their deaths as if they are merely additions to the road toll, an abnormal willingness to treat them as an inevitable part of modern life. There were other reasons that public fears were subdued. For one, the distance between Adelaide and the dumping ground created a false sense of safety for those who lived in the city and its surrounding suburbs. Secondly, almost two years had passed since the killer last struck,
一位记者指出，对凶手的愤怒和呐喊明显缺失。悉尼先驱晨报的一篇文章写道，阿德莱德似乎已经接受了她们的死亡，仿佛它们只是交通事故死亡人数的增加，这种对将它们视为现代生活不可避免的一部分的异常意愿。公众恐惧得到平息还有其他原因。一方面，阿德莱德与抛尸地之间的距离为那些住在城市及周边郊区的人创造了一种虚假的安全感。其次，距离凶手上次行凶已经过去了近两年，
so the majority simply didn't view the serial killer as a looming threat. Given the skeletal state of the remains, there was also no forensic evidence to indicate how any of the young women had died. As one psychologist explained, this fact also hindered emotional reaction. He stated the remains were, quote, Just bones and rotten material, not young girls we can relate to. Undeterred by the lackluster public response, investigators worked tirelessly to solve the case. They reassessed more than 10,000 files of people who had gone missing from South Australia from 1975 onwards to see if any of them fit the same pattern as the slain women. They reexamined reports of attempted abductions that occurred during late 1976 and early 1977 and found they had a number of reports on file.
因此大多数人根本不认为连环杀手是一个逼近的威胁。鉴于遗骸的骨骼状态，也没有法医证据表明这些年轻女性是如何死亡的。正如一位心理学家所解释的那样，这一事实也阻碍了情感反应。他指出，这些遗骸是，引号，只是骨头和腐烂的物质，而不是我们可以产生共鸣的年轻女孩。在对公众冷淡反应毫不气馁的情况下，调查人员夜以继日地努力破案。他们重新评估了1975年以来南澳大利亚失踪人员的10,000多份档案，看看其中是否有符合被杀女性相同模式的人。他们重新审查了1976年末至1977年初发生的企图绑架报告，并发现他们手头有许多此类报告。
Anyone who had witnessed an attempted abduction during this time was asked to come forward and a reward of $30,000 for information that led to an arrest was announced. Anyone with information who wasn't directly involved with the murders was promised a pardon, but despite the reward being a significant amount of money for the era, nobody came forward. At the time, criminal profiling was in its infancy and this new technique was applied to try and pinpoint the likely traits of the Truro killer. A criminologist deduced that the perpetrator likely lived in the inner suburbs of Adelaide and came across as a normal individual who was indistinguishable from anyone else in the community. His first murder had likely stemmed from a sexual encounter with a woman that had gone awry and after realising he could get away with it with no public outcry, he gained the confidence to do it again. He kept returning to Truro to dump the bodies because he felt confident that they wouldn't be found. He might have been a lonely individual and interpreted his victims as troubled or unlikely to be missed.
在此期间目击过企图绑架案的任何人被要求站出来，并宣布悬赏3万澳元以获取能够导致逮捕的信息。向任何未直接参与谋杀但掌握信息的知情者承诺免于起诉，但尽管这笔赏金对那个时代来说是一笔可观的巨款，却没有人站出来。当时，犯罪侧写还处于起步阶段，这种新技术被应用于试图查明特鲁罗杀手的可能特征。一位犯罪学家推测，作案者很可能是阿德莱德内城郊区的居民，表现得像个正常人，与社区中的任何人没有区别。他的第一起谋杀很可能源于与一个女性的性接触出了岔子，在意识到自己可以逃脱且没有引起公众抗议后，他获得了再次作案的自信。他不断回到特鲁罗抛尸，因为他确信尸体不会被找到。他可能是一个孤独的人，并将他的受害者视为有麻烦或不太可能被怀念的人。
One of the biggest questions was why the killer had stopped. His crime spree had taken place in a short period of time with a suspected total of seven women abducted and murdered within just a seven week time frame. Veronica Knight and Tanya Kenney had gone missing one week apart whereas Sylvia Pittman, Connie Jordanides and Vicki Howell vanished within just days of one another. This meant the killer had escalated at a rapid pace. Deborah Lamb then disappeared three days later and after that there were no more suspected victims. So why stop so suddenly? Criminologists believed the killer had either died or been arrested on an unrelated charge and incarcerated. They looked into criminals with a record of violent offending, hoping to identify anyone who fit the profile.
最大的谜团之一是凶手为什么会收手。他的犯罪狂潮发生在很短的一段时间内，据信在短短七周内共有七名女性被绑架和谋杀。维罗妮卡·奈特（Veronica Knight）和塔尼娅·肯尼（Tanya Kenney）是在一周之内相继失踪的，而西尔维娅·皮特曼（Sylvia Pittman）、康妮·乔丹尼德斯（Connie Jordanides）和薇姬·豪厄尔（Vicki Howell）则在几天之内相继消失。这意味着凶手的犯罪升级速度极快。三天后，黛博拉·兰姆（Deborah Lamb）也失踪了，此后便再也没有疑似受害者。那么，为什么要突然收手呢？犯罪学家认为，凶手要么已经死亡，要么因另一项罪名被捕并收监。他们调查了有暴力犯罪记录的罪犯，希望能找出符合这一特征的人。
Desperate for answers, the reward for information was increased to $40,000. This time it was enough to encourage someone to speak. 32 year old James Miller was exercising in the remand yard of Adelaide Jail when he looked over and caught sight of a young man he had never seen before. To Miller, the young inmate didn't look like a typical criminal. He had a clean look with no tattoos and seemed to take pride in his appearance. Miller, who had weathered skin and was slightly balding, was instantly struck by the young man's good looks. Miller himself was no stranger to institutions. Born Melville Raymond Juss, before later changing his name via Deedpaal, he was raised in a poor family of six children in Adelaide's West.
由于急需答案，提供线索的悬赏金被提高到了4万美元。这一次，悬赏金额终于足够让人开口了。32岁的詹姆斯·米勒（James Miller）正在阿德莱德监狱（Adelaide Jail）的还押操场上锻炼身体，这时他抬头瞥见了一个从未见过的年轻男子。在米勒看来，这个年轻的囚犯看起来不像个典型的罪犯。他面容干净，没有纹身，似乎很注重仪容。米勒饱经风霜、略微秃顶，当即被这个年轻人的美貌所吸引。米勒本人也是个监狱常客。他出生时名叫梅尔维尔·雷蒙德·朱斯（Melville Raymond Juss），后来通过变更姓名契约（Deedpoll）改了名，在阿德莱德西部的一个有六个孩子的贫困家庭中长大。
He began stealing at a young age and by 11 he was sent to live in a reformatory in the eastern suburbs. By 15 he fled the reformatory, stole a car and drove it into state. He was eventually caught and sentenced to hard labor in New South Wales's Long Bay Jail. From that point on, James Miller was in and out of jail for a range of non-violent offences including theft, larceny and breaking and entering. He didn't have any close friends and considered himself to be a lone wolf. Miller was gay and when he caught sight of the young new inmate across the remand yard, he felt an immediate attraction. The inmate appeared to be in his late teens and was about five foot seven inches tall with shoulder length shiny black hair and a warm, friendly smile. The inmate introduced himself as 20 year old Christopher Robin Warrell.
他很小就开始偷窃，11岁就被送去东郊的一家教养所。15岁时，他逃离教养所，偷了一辆汽车并一路开出了州。他最终被抓获，并在新南威尔士州的朗贝i监狱（Long Bay Jail）被判处苦役。从那时起，詹姆斯·米勒因盗窃、偷盗和入室盗窃等一系列非暴力犯罪而频繁进出监狱。他没有什么亲密的朋友，认为自己是一匹孤狼。米勒是个同性恋，当他在还押操场上瞥见那个年轻的新囚犯时，他顿时产生了一种吸引力。这个囚犯看起来二十岁出头，身高约五英尺七英寸，留着齐肩的亮黑色头发，带着温暖友善的微笑。这名囚犯自我介绍说，他是20岁的克里斯托弗·罗宾·沃雷尔（Christopher Robin Warrell）。
Warrell had been raised by his grandmother and left high school to serve three years in the Royal Australian Air Force. He was discharged after being deemed incompatible with service life. This was his first time in jail, although he had a prior suspended sentence for armed robbery after he had robbed a hitchhiker of $1.50. This time he'd been accused of rape, a crime which he staunchly denied. Chris Warrell explained to Miller that he'd been drunk driving when he picked up a female hitchhiker and the two had engaged in sex. Afterwards, the woman accused him of raping her, but Warrell was too intoxicated to remember any of the details. Miller immediately believed Warrell when he said he was innocent. He was simply too good looking and too charming to have to resort to rape.
沃雷尔由祖母抚养长大，高中辍学后在澳大利亚皇家空军服役三年。因被认为不适合军旅生活，他被勒令退伍。这是他第一次入狱，尽管他此前曾因抢劫一名搭便车者1.5美元而被判武装抢劫缓刑。这一次，他被指控强奸，但他坚决否认这一罪名。克里斯·沃雷尔向米勒解释说，他在酒后驾车时搭载了一名女性搭便车者，两人发生了性关系。事后，那名女子指控他强奸，但沃雷尔当时醉得不省人事，根本记不清任何细节。米勒立刻相信了沃雷尔的无辜。他觉得对方长得太帅、太有魅力了，根本不需要沦落到去强奸。
Miller and Warrell began chatting and over the next few days a friendship bloomed. They were an unlikely pair, Warrell was confident and arrogant, whereas Miller was self-conscious and submissive, but their opposing personalities meshed perfectly. Within a week, they had requested to move into a cell together. From that point on, the two men spent all their time together. They decided to solidify their bond by becoming blood brothers. A ritual that involved them each slicing their own wrist and then placing their two bleeding wounds together. One night, out of nowhere, Warrell turned to Miller and said, I am a psychopathic killer. Miller wasn't sure what to make of the comet.
米勒和沃雷尔开始聊天，在接下来的几天里，一段友谊迅速萌芽。他们是一对很不相配的组合：沃雷尔自信而傲慢，而米勒则自卑且顺从，但他们截然不到的性格却完美地契合在了一起。一周之内，他们就申请搬进同一个牢房。从那时起，这两个人把所有时间都泡在了一起。他们决定通过成为血盟兄弟来巩固彼此的纽带。这是一个仪式，两人各自割破自己的手腕，然后将两个流血的伤口贴在一起。一天晚上，沃雷尔毫无征兆地转向米勒说：“我是一个精神病杀手。”米勒不知道该怎么看待这句话。
Was Warrell being serious or just trying to scare him? He brushed it off, but Warrell's words stayed with him. Warrell was eventually found guilty of the rape and sentenced to six years in Yatla prison. Miller was released shortly after, but it wasn't long before he was arrested again, this time for stealing more than 4,000 pairs of sunglasses. He was sentenced to 18 months in Yatla and was relieved to be reunited with his blood brother. The pair's bond continued to strengthen and they began making plans to live together on the outside. On February 11, 1976, James Miller was finally released, but as an ex-con, he wasn't allowed to visit the jail until he'd been free for a year. To skirt around this rule, he began disguising himself as a woman in order to visit Warrell.
沃雷尔是认真的，还是只是想吓唬他？他把这话抛在了脑后，但沃雷尔的话一直萦绕在他心头。沃雷尔最终被裁定强奸罪名成立，在亚特拉监狱（Yatla prison）被判处六年监禁。米勒不久后获释，但没过多久他又被捕了，这一次是因为偷窃了4000多副太阳镜。他在亚特拉监狱被判处18个月监禁，并庆幸能与他的血兄弟团聚。两人的纽带不断加深，他们开始计划出狱后一起生活。1976年2月11日，詹姆斯·米勒终于刑满释放，但作为一名刑满释放人员，他必须在获得自由一年后才能探监。为了钻这个规则的空子，他开始把自己打扮成女人去探望沃雷尔。
17 months into Warrell's sentence, he applied for parole. During his time behind bars, the only rule he had broken was owning a forbidden gold earring. Otherwise, he'd been a model prisoner. Warrell's parole officer visited his mother and stepfather to ask if they were prepared to accept Warrell back into their home. They weren't, saying they were worried that he'd be a bad influence on his younger brother. Partly because of this, his application for parole was denied. In June of 1976, Warrell applied for parole for the second time and this time his application was successful. After serving just two years of his six-year sentence, Warrell was released at the age of 23.
在沃雷尔服刑17个月后，他申请了假释。在铁窗生涯中，他违反的唯一规矩就是拥有一只违禁的金耳环。除此之外，他一直是个模范囚犯。沃雷尔的假释官拜访了他的母亲和继父，询问他们是否准备好接受沃雷尔回家。他们拒绝了，称他们担心沃雷尔会对他的弟弟产生不良影响。部分由于这个原因，他的假释申请被驳回了。1976年6月，沃雷尔第二次申请假释，这一次他的申请获批了。在服完六年刑期的两年后，沃雷尔在23岁时获释了。
The two cellmates were reunited on the outside at last. They spent every day together, sleeping at Miller's sister's house or at the homes of other friends while they tried to get enough money together for their own flat. They borrowed cars from friends and co-workers whenever they could while saving up to buy a car of their own. Both men got a job doing outdoor work for the council and they spent their spare time cruising the streets of Adelaide, frequenting the local pubs and picking up women. Chris Warrell had an appealing charm and confidence about him and coupled with his boyish good looks, women were naturally attracted to him. He had no trouble approaching women on the street and convincing them to come for a ride with him. If they ever seemed wary about Miller's presence, Warrell would tell them that Miller was his father or uncle, which put them at ease.
两个狱友终于在外面重聚了。他们每天都在一起，睡在米勒姐姐家或其他朋友家里，同时努力攒钱买一套属于他们自己的公寓。他们一有机会就向朋友和同事借车，同时攒钱买一辆属于自己的车。两人都在议会找到了一份户外清洁的工作，闲暇时他们会开着车在阿德莱德的街道上兜风，常去当地的酒吧搭讪女性。克里斯·沃雷尔有一种吸引人的魅力和自信，再加上他那充满男孩气的英俊外表，女性自然会被他吸引。他在街上搭讪女性并说服她们搭他的顺风车毫不费力。如果她们对米勒的存在感到警惕，沃雷尔就会告诉她们米勒是他的父亲或叔叔，这让她们打消了顾虑。
Miller acted as Warrell's driver, eager to please the younger man in whatever way he could. When Warrell would pick up girls, Miller would leave them alone in the car to have sex. Although Miller himself had a romantic interest in Warrell, he was never jealous of Warrell's sexual exploits with women. It simply pleased him to see his friend happy. Warrell had an obsession with pornography and bondage and the two men began frequenting Adelaide sex shops so that Warrell could peruse the shelves for bondage magazines to buy and trade. Although Warrell considered himself to be heterosexual, he'd had dalliances with some male inmates during his time in jail. Outside, he also had some sexual encounters with drag queens. Miller avoided making any sexual advances towards Warrell out of fear of driving him away, but their relationship soon took a turn when Warrell allowed Miller to perform oral sex on him while he read bondage magazines.
米勒充当沃雷尔的司机，渴望以各种可能的方式取悦这个年轻人。当沃雷尔搭讪到女孩时，米勒会把她们独自留在车里发生性关系。尽管米勒对沃雷尔有着浪漫的爱慕之情，但他从未嫉妒过沃雷尔与女性的性爱经历。看到自己的朋友快乐，他本身就感到高兴。沃雷尔对色情和捆绑有着迷恋，两人开始频繁光顾阿德莱德的性用品商店，以便沃雷尔可以浏览货架上的捆绑杂志来购买和交换。尽管沃雷尔认为自己是异性恋，但他在狱中曾与一些男囚犯有过风流韵事。在外面，他也和变装皇后有过几次性接触。米勒避免对沃雷尔做出任何性方面的追求，生怕把对方吓跑，但当沃雷尔允许米勒在自己阅读捆绑杂志时为其口交时，他们的关系很快发生了转变。
Miller was thrilled about this development, hoping it would bond the two even closer together, but for Warrell, it was purely about pleasure. His focus remained on picking up women for quick one-night stands, women whom he referred to as rags. The more time the two men spent together, the clearer it became that there was more to Chris Warrell than the easygoing, charming person he presented himself to be. Warrell suffered from dark moods that would come on seemingly out of nowhere. The two mates could be having a great time, and then without warning, it was as though a dark cloud would descend upon Warrell. His carefree persona suddenly switched, and he started acting like a different person, as though he had entered a blackout and wasn't aware of how he was acting. These moods often caught Miller off guard. He didn't trust Warrell when a mood overtook him and did whatever he could to pacify his friend.
米勒对这一进展感到欣喜若狂，希望这能让两人的关系更加紧密，但对沃雷尔来说，这纯粹是为了享乐。他的重心仍然放在搭讪女性进行短暂的一夜情上，他把这些女性称为“破布”。这两个人在一起的时间越多，就越发清楚地表明，克里斯·沃雷尔不仅仅是一个他所表现出的那种随和、迷人的人。沃雷尔患有阴暗的情绪问题，这些情绪似乎会毫无征兆地袭来。两个伙伴本来可能玩得很开心，接着毫无预兆地，仿佛有一片乌云降临到沃雷尔身上。他无忧无虑的面具突然转变，开始表现得像另一个人，仿佛他进入了意识空白期，并且不知道自己是怎么行事的。这些情绪常常让米勒措手不及。当情绪控制沃雷尔时，米勒并不信任他，并尽其所能地安抚他的朋友。
On one occasion, they were at the dog races when Warrell entered one of his dark moods. He walked out onto the busy main road and into oncoming traffic, as though daring cars to hit him. Miller left him alone out of fear that Warrell would jump in front of a car if he tried to intervene. He learned to back off and just wait for the moods to dissipate. They were typically brief, and Warrell would usually take himself for a walk and emerge from the darkness a short time later, as if nothing had ever happened. One day, Miller suggested to Warrell that he should see a doctor about his moods. Miller was concerned that his friend might have an underlying medical condition that was causing him to act irrationally. Warrell refused, leaving Miller to worry about him constantly and live on edge, not knowing when one of the dark moods would strike.
有一次，他们在看狗赛时，沃雷尔陷入了阴暗的情绪中。他走到繁忙的主干道上，步入迎面而来的车流中，仿佛在挑衅汽车撞他。米勒没有理会他，因为害怕如果自己试图干涉，沃雷尔会跳到车前。他学会了退缩，只等着这种情绪消散。它们通常很短暂，沃雷尔通常会自己出去散散步，不久后便从阴霾中走出来，就好像什么都没发生过一样。一天，米勒建议沃雷尔应该去看医生，看看自己的情绪问题。米勒担心他的朋友可能有某种潜在的健康状况，导致其行为不理智。沃雷尔拒绝了，这让米勒整天为他担心，活在提心吊胆之中，不知道什么时候这种阴暗情绪又会再次发作。
Miller believed the reason Warrell wouldn't seek help was because he feared he'd be forced to undergo electric shock treatment or be given medication that would alter the good parts of his personality. But the moods continued to get worse and more frequent. Things started happening that Miller had no control over. Bad things. Then one night, around November 1976, Miller and Warrell were out drinking at a pub when they met a woman named Amelia. She and Warrell immediately hit it off. Amelia had a strong belief in reincarnation and thought that Warrell had been a Native American chief in a past life. The two began casually dating, although Warrell continued to pick up women for sex.
米勒认为沃雷尔不愿寻求帮助的原因是，他害怕自己被迫接受电击治疗或服用会改变其性格中美好部分的药物。但这些情绪继续恶化，而且发作得更加频繁。开始发生一些米勒无法控制的事情。糟糕的事情。然后，在大约1976年11月的一个晚上，米勒和沃雷尔在一家酒吧喝酒时，遇到了一位名叫阿梅莉亚（Amelia）的女性。她和沃雷尔一见如故。阿梅莉亚坚信轮回转世，认为沃雷尔在前世是一位美洲原住民酋长。两人开始随意约会，尽管沃雷尔仍然继续搭讪女性发生性关系。
One day at work, Warrell made a remark to his coworkers that sent a wave of panic through Miller. Warrell usually bragged about his exploits, but this day he said he was thinking of going on the straight and narrow. He thought it might be time to settle down and start a family. For Miller, this was terrible news. If Warrell left him, he would have no one. Warrell and Miller weren't the only ones going through a tense time in Adelaide. Their close friend, Debbie Scoose, was having troubles with her partner. A man Warrell and Miller had spent time with in jail, so the trio thought it might do them all some good to get out of town for the weekend. They decided to take a road trip to Mount Gambia, a small city on the limestone coast that lay halfway between Adelaide and Melbourne.
一天在上班时，沃雷尔对同事说了一句话，在米勒心中引发了一阵恐慌。沃雷尔平时总是吹嘘自己的风流韵事，但这一天他说他考虑走正道。他觉得也许是时候安定下来，组建一个家庭了。对米勒来说，这是一个可怕的消息。如果沃雷尔离开了他，他就一无所有了。沃雷尔和米勒并不是阿德莱德唯一经历紧张时期的人。他们的密友黛比·斯科斯（Debbie Scoose）与伴侣遇到了麻烦。这个男人是沃雷尔和米勒在狱中一起相处过的人，所以三人觉得离开小镇过个周末对大家都有好处。他们决定来一场公路旅行，去往位于阿德莱德和墨尔本中途、石灰石海岸（limestone coast）上的一座小城市芒特甘比尔（Mount Gambier）。
The five-hour drive would give them all some time to clear their heads, and a change of scenery would surely do them good. By this point, Miller and Warrell had leased a car from a car yard, but it had been playing up and was in the process of being repaired. They were able to borrow a replacement vehicle from the car dealer, an old white Plymouth Valiant station wagon. They departed for Mount Gambia in the Valiant late at night on Friday, February 18, 1977, arriving in the early hours of Saturday morning. The trip started out decently, with the trio visiting the famous Blue Lake and browsing some local shops. Miller and Warrell were looking through a sports store when they came across a shotgun. On a whim, they decided to buy it so they could stop and go rabbit hunting on the drive back to Adelaide. By chance, they then stumbled upon a historical aircraft display that was taking place at the Mount Gambia airport.
五个小时的车程将给他们所有人一些时间来清醒头脑，而风景的变换肯定会对他们大有裨益。此时，米勒和沃雷尔从一个车场租了一辆车，但它一直出毛病，目前正在修理中。他们得以从汽车经销商那里借了一辆代步车，那是一辆旧白色的普利茅斯·英杰（Plymouth Valiant）旅行车。他们于1977年2月18日星期五深夜驾驶着这辆英杰出发前往芒特甘比尔，并在周六清晨抵达。旅行以相当不错的方式开始，三人参观了著名的蓝湖（Blue Lake），并浏览了一些当地的商店。米勒和沃雷尔正在一家体育用品店里浏览时，偶然看到了一支猎枪。出于一时兴起，他们决定买下它，这样在开车返回阿德莱德的路上，他们就可以停下来去打兔子。机缘巧合之下，他们随后又偶然碰到了正在芒特甘比尔机场举办的的历史飞机展。
Warrell was a huge aircraft buff, so the trio decided to check it out. As they lined up for tickets, Warrell was chatting jovially when he suddenly entered one of his dark moods. He demanded they return to their motel immediately. Miller was used to these moods by now and recognized it as a warning sign. Not wanting Debbie to be exposed to Warrell's dangerous side, Miller suggested they drive back to Adelaide that afternoon. The others agreed. The day was blazing hot. They filled the Valiant with petrol, pumped up the worn out tyres and bought a carton of beer for the journey.
沃雷尔是个狂热的飞机迷，于是三人决定去看看。当他们排队买票时，沃雷尔正谈笑风生，突然就陷入了阴暗的情绪中。他要求他们立刻返回汽车旅馆。米勒此时已经习惯了这些情绪，并将其识别为一个危险信号。由于不想让黛比暴露在沃雷尔危险的一面中，米勒建议他们当天下午就开车回阿德莱德。其他人表示同意。天气炎热如火。他们给英杰加满了汽油，打满了磨损的轮胎，并为旅程买了一箱啤酒。
As Miller drove along the highway, Warrell was sullen and began drinking. They hadn't made it far out of Mount Gambia when they picked up a female hitchhiker which temporarily lifted Warrell's spirits. After dropping her at her destination, Miller was feeling tired and asked Warrell to take over driving. By this point it was around 5.30pm and Warrell had consumed several cans of beer. Although he didn't seem intoxicated, Debbie was worried that his drinking might impair his driving. Miller wasn't concerned at first, but as Warrell sat behind the wheel, it became clear that his dark mood hadn't yet lifted. Warrell pressed his foot against the accelerator and quickly picked up speed. From the passenger seat, Debbie begged him to slow down while Miller remained silent in the back, not wanting to upset Warrell further.
当米勒开车沿着公路行驶时，沃雷尔阴沉着脸开始喝酒。他们刚离开芒特甘比尔没多久，就搭上了一名女性搭便车者，这暂时提振了沃雷尔的精神。在将她送到目的地后，米勒感到很累，便让沃雷尔接替开车。此时大约是下午5点30分，沃雷尔已经喝了好几罐啤酒。尽管他看起来没有喝醉，但黛比担心他的饮酒可能会影响驾驶。米勒起初并不担心，但当沃雷尔坐在方向盘后面时，人们清楚地看到他的阴暗情绪还没有消散。沃雷尔将脚踩在油门上，迅速加速。坐在副驾驶座上的黛比恳求他慢点开，而米勒则在后座上保持沉默，不想进一步惹恼沃雷尔。
Debbie's fears only seemed to wag Warrell on. He drove even faster, telling Debbie, Go ahead, have a good cry. Suddenly, as they sped down the highway towards the coastal town of Kingston, there was a loud bang. One of the tyres had blown out. Warrell lost control of the vehicle, swerving it across the road as another car came towards them head on. He regained control, but only for a moment. The car flipped. It rolled over and over, feeling like it would never stop.
黛比的恐惧似乎反而激起了沃雷尔的兴致。他开得更快了，对黛比说：“去吧，痛快地哭一场吧。”突然，当他们沿着公路向沿海小镇金斯顿（Kingston）疾驰时，一声巨响传来。其中一个轮胎爆了。沃雷尔失去了对车辆的控制，在一辆迎面驶来的汽车驶向他们时，方向盘猛打，将车横穿了马路。他重新控制住了车，但只有短短一瞬。车翻了。它翻了又翻，感觉仿佛永远不会停下来。
Eventually, everything was still. The car came to a stop, standing the right way up. Miller slowly crawled out. His shoulder was broken, but he was in too much shock to notice the pain. He looked around, and a short distance from the car, he saw Debbie and Warrell lying on the road, completely still, with blood pulled around them. Both had been thrown from the vehicle at high speed. Several other motorists had stopped and rushed over to help. Miller heard one of them say,
最终，一切都平静了下来。车停了下来，正向朝上。米勒缓慢地爬了出来。他的肩膀骨折了，但他处于极度震惊之中，根本感觉不到疼痛。他环顾四周，离车不远处的路上，他看到黛比和沃雷尔一动不动地躺着，周围聚着一滩血。两人都以极高的速度被甩出了车外。其他几名司机停下车，冲过来帮忙。米勒听到其中一人说：
They are both dead. James Miller was utterly devastated by the loss of his best friend Chris Warrell. He blamed himself, convinced that if he hadn't suggested the group leave Mount Gambier a day early, that Warrell and Debbie's goose would still be alive. He didn't know how he was going to function without his sidekick around, the only person he'd ever been truly close to. To make matters worse, Warrell's family forbade him from attending the funeral. He went anyway, visiting the gravesite beforehand. He jumped into the hole and buried a treasured photo of Warrell with a note written on the back that read, Chris, please try and understand me.
“他们都死了。”失去挚友克里斯·沃雷尔让詹姆斯·米勒痛不欲生。他将责任归咎于自己，坚信如果不是自己建议大家提前一天离开芒特甘比尔，沃雷尔和黛比现在肯定还活着。他不知道没有了这个在身边的死党，自己该如何生活下去——这是他唯一一个真正亲近过的人。更糟糕的是，沃雷尔的家属禁止他出席葬礼。他还是去了，提前去拜访了墓地。他跳进墓穴，埋下了沃雷尔的一张珍贵照片，背面写着一张字条上面写道：“克里斯，请试着理解我。”
I love you as a mate and always will. Hope to see you soon. Please forgive me. After the funeral, a small group gathered at the home of one of Warrell's friends. They stood in the kitchen, chatting about Warrell. Warrell's girlfriend Amelia was still trying to come to terms with the day's events. She was deeply upset about the sudden loss of her boyfriend and was overcome with grief. In a bid to comfort her, Amelia turned to Amelia and said,
“我作为朋友爱着你，而且永远都会。希望很快能见到你。请原谅我。”葬礼结束后，一小群人聚集在沃雷尔的一位朋友家里。他们站在厨房里，闲聊着沃雷尔。沃雷尔的女友阿梅莉亚仍然在努力接受当天的发生的事情。她对男友的突然离世感到深深的悲痛，被悲伤压垮了。为了安慰她，阿梅莉亚转向阿梅莉亚说：
There's more to it than you know. He asked if he could have a word with Amelia outside. She agreed and followed him into the back garden. Amelia then asked her a strange question. Did you like Chris? Amelia was taken aback but replied that yes she did. Amelia then said, Well, you wouldn't if you knew what I knew about him.
“事情比你知道的还要复杂。”他问阿梅莉亚是否能单独聊聊。她同意了，并跟着他走到后花园。接着，阿梅莉亚问了她一个奇怪的问题：“你喜欢克里斯吗？”阿梅莉亚大吃一惊，但回答说是的，她喜欢。然后阿梅莉亚说：“好吧，如果你知道我对他了解的情况，你就不会喜欢了。”
Amelia asked what he was talking about. Miller started to cry and responded ominously. Chris had to die. The weeks and months following the car crash dragged on for Miller. Without his sidekick, he felt completely lost and alone, describing that life without Chris was an empty sea. He quit his job with the council and spent his days wandering around aimlessly, doing menial tasks at homeless shelters for a place to stay overnight,
阿梅莉亚问他在说什么。米勒开始哭泣，并 ominous 地回应道：“克里斯必须死。”车祸之后的几周和几个月对米勒来说度日如年。没有了死党，他感到彻底的迷失和孤独，形容没有克里斯的生活就像一片空旷的大海。他辞去了议会的工作，整天漫无目的地游荡，在无家可归者收容所做些琐碎的杂务以换取一个过夜的地方，
or otherwise sleeping rough. On the one year anniversary of the crash, Miller placed a memorial for Warrell in the local newspaper that read, Christopher Robin Warrell, memories of a very close friend who died 12 months ago this week. Your friendship and thoughtfulness and kindness will always be remembered by me, mate. What comes after death, I can hope, as I pray we meet again. By May of 1979, Chris Warrell had been dead for almost two years,
或者露宿街头。在车祸一周年纪念日，米勒在当地报纸上为沃雷尔刊登了一则纪念启事，上面写着：“克里斯托弗·罗宾·沃雷尔，对12个月前的本周去世的一位非常亲密的朋友的记忆。朋友，你的友谊、体贴和善良将永远被我铭记。死后会发生什么，我只能希望，正如我祈祷我们能再次相聚。”到1979年5月，克里斯·沃雷尔已经去世快两年了，
but Miller was still struggling to come to terms with his grief. Accompanying his grief was an impending sense of dread. The news of the bodies found at Truro was making headlines, and with the reward for information bolstered to $40,000, Miller felt like it was a matter of time before the truth was revealed. On Wednesday, May 23, the now 38-year-old Miller was mopping the floors at the Adelaide Central Mission Drop-In Centre near Whitmore Square in the CBD. He peered out the window and noticed a woman sitting in a car, watching him.
但米勒仍然在努力应对自己的悲痛。伴随着悲痛而来的是一种迫在眉睫的恐惧感。特鲁罗（Truro）发现尸体的新闻成了头条新闻，随着提供线索的悬赏金增加到4万美元，米勒觉得真相大白只是时间问题。5月23日星期三，当时38岁的米勒正在CBD惠特莫尔广场（Whitmore Square）附近的阿德莱德中央教会日间中心（Adelaide Central Mission Drop-In Centre）擦地板。他透过窗户向外张望，注意到一个女人坐在一辆车里盯着他看。
He wasn't sure if he was just being paranoid, but he didn't want to take any chances. He put down the mop and left the centre via a rear door, walking hurriedly around the corner towards the Adelaide Central Markets. Despite being one of the largest undercover fresh produce markets in the Southern Hemisphere, the aisles were mostly deserted. Traders didn't gather on Wednesdays, so the fruit and vegetable stores were bare, with no shoppers inside. Unbeknownst to Miller, a team of eight officers were surveilling him at that very moment.
他不确定自己是不是被迫害妄想发作，但他不想冒任何风险。他放下拖把，从后门离开中心，匆忙绕过街角朝阿德莱德中央市场（Adelaide Central Markets）走去。尽管这里是南半球最大的室内生鲜市场之一，但通道里大多空无一人。周三商贩们不开市，因此水果和蔬菜店空空如也，里面没有购物者。米勒并不知道，一队八名警员当时正在监视他。
They watched as he made his way through the deserted market aisles, his awareness of their presence becoming increasingly obvious as he quickly gathered pace. He turned a corner towards the market's southern entrance on Goodyear Street and began to run. He turned a corner towards the market's southern entrance on Goodyear Street, and began to run. That's when he heard a voice yell, stop. Miller was taken to a small interview room at the police headquarters just a few streets away.
他们看着他穿过空无一人的市场通道，随着他迅速加快步伐，他意识到他们存在的事迹变得越来越明显。他转过街角，朝古德伊尔街（Goodyear Street）的市场南入口走去，开始奔跑。他转过街角，朝古德伊尔街的市场南入口走去，并开始奔跑。就在这时，他听到一个声音大喊：“站住。”米勒被带到几条街外警察总部的一个小型审讯室里。
The interviewing detective said they wanted to talk to Miller about something that happened two years prior. Miller said he had no idea what the officer was talking about. The detective pressed on, asking if Miller knew Christopher Worrell. Miller replied, Yeah, I've heard of him. The detective then said, We have received information that you and Chris Worrell have been picking up girls and killing them. Miller denied this accusation, saying,
审讯侦探表示，他们想和米勒谈谈两年前发生的一件事。米勒说他根本不知道警官在说什么。侦探步步紧逼，问米勒是否认识克里斯托弗·沃雷尔（Christopher Worrell）。米勒回答说：“是的，我听说过他。”侦探接着说：“我们接到消息，你和克里斯·沃雷尔一直在搭讪女孩并杀害她们。”米勒否认了这一指控，说道：
Chris was a good looking bloke and didn't have to do that. He continued to answer questions about his relationship with Worrell, but said he had no knowledge about any of the women whose bodies had been dumped out near Truro. The detective pressed on for almost five hours, with Miller denying everything that was presented to him. That was until investigators revealed they'd spoken to Worrell's old girlfriend, Amelia. After all this time,
“克里斯是个帅小伙，根本不需要做那种事。”他继续回答有关他与沃雷尔关系的问题，但表示他对在特鲁罗附近被抛弃尸体的女性一无所知。侦探们盘问了近五个小时，米勒对摆在他面前的一切全盘否认。直到调查人员透露他们已经与沃雷尔的前女友阿梅莉亚交谈过。事到如今，
Amelia was still coming to terms with the conversation she had had with Miller following Worrell's funeral. Miller had been overcome with emotion when he told Amelia that she didn't know the real Chris. He explained about Worrell's dark moods and blackouts, and then made a shocking confession. He and Worrell had been picking up girls, and Worrell had been raping and strangling them. Their bodies were then dumped near Blanchtown, a town 45 kilometers east of Truro.
阿梅莉亚仍然在努力接受她在沃雷尔葬礼后与米勒的那次谈话。当米勒告诉阿梅莉亚她并不了解真正的克里斯时，他情绪失控。他向她讲述了沃雷尔的阴暗情绪和意识空白期，然后做出了一个惊人的供认。他和沃雷尔一直在搭讪女孩，而沃雷尔一直在强奸并勒死她们。随后，她们的尸体被抛在距离特鲁罗以东45公里的布兰奇敦（Blanchtown）附近。
Miller told Amelia, quote, one of them even enjoyed it. Amelia had been speechless. She couldn't believe what she was hearing, but judging by Miller's emotional reaction, he didn't seem to be lying. She knew Miller and Worrell to be nothing but friends, she knew Miller and Worrell to be nothing but friendly and kind individuals.
米勒告诉阿梅莉亚，原话是：“其中一个甚至还很享受。”阿梅莉亚当时说不出话来。她简直不敢相信自己听到的话，但从米勒情绪化的反应来看，他似乎没有撒谎。她只知道米勒和沃雷尔是朋友，她知道米勒和沃雷尔除了友好和善良之外什么都不是。
She knew they both had a criminal history, but Worrell had told her he only served time for robbery and never mentioned anything about the rape charge. Miller had told Amelia that if she didn't believe him, he would take her out and show her the bodies. At the time, Amelia didn't know what to do. She had recently learned about Worrell's blackouts from his mother, who suspected her son might have a brain tumor caused by a head injury
她知道他们都有犯罪记录，但沃雷尔曾告诉她，他只因抢劫服过刑，从未提过任何关于强奸指控的事。米勒曾告诉阿梅莉亚，如果她不相信他，他会带她出去看尸体。当时，阿梅莉亚不知道该怎么办。她最近从沃雷尔的母亲那里得知了沃雷尔的意识空白期，他的母亲怀疑她儿子可能患有由头部受伤引起的脑瘤，
that he suffered during his time in the Air Force. Amelia believed Miller's story, but was at a loss about what to do with the information. Miller insisted he only acted as the driver, and it was Worrell who had killed the girls. If this was true, Amelia rationalized there was no point telling anyone. The killer was dead,
那是他在空军服役期间遭受的。阿梅莉亚相信了米勒的故事，但对于如何处理这些信息感到无所适从。米勒坚称自己只是充当司机，是沃雷尔杀害了这些女孩。如果这是真的，阿梅莉亚理智地认为告诉任何人都没有意义。凶手已经死了，
and she didn't want to see Miller unfairly blamed for someone else's crimes. Amelia never called in the tip-off, but she confided in a friend who subsequently contacted the authorities when the reward money was announced. The detectives told Miller they had since spoken to Amelia, and she was incredibly distressed about the situation. Miller didn't believe them. He said that if Amelia had given them this false information,
她不想看到米勒为别人的罪行受到不公正的指责。阿梅莉亚从未打举报电话，但她向一位朋友吐露了心声，后者在悬赏金公布后联系了当局。侦探们告诉米勒，他们此后已经和阿梅莉亚谈过，她对目前的状况感到非常痛苦。米勒不相信他们。他说，如果阿梅莉亚给了他们这些虚假信息，
she must have been desperate for the reward money. The detectives then claimed Amelia had told them she was worried that Worrell's soul would never be free unless the rest of the bodies were found. Upon hearing this, Miller knew the detectives must be telling the truth. Amelia was a spiritual person who had strong beliefs about reincarnation, so this seemed like a genuine concern that she would have.
她肯定是急于得到悬赏金。侦探随后声称，阿梅莉亚告诉他们，她担心除非找到其余的尸体，否则沃雷尔的灵魂将永远得不到自由。听到这里，米勒知道侦探们说的肯定是实话。阿梅莉亚是一个有着强烈轮回转世信仰的精神化人物，所以这似乎是她会产生的真诚担忧。
The thought of Amelia being caught up in this mess upset Miller. He asked for a minute alone to think. He came to the decision that he would talk as long as Amelia and Worrell would be kept out of things moving forward. The detective agreed. Miller said, I suppose I've got nothing to look forward to whatever way it goes, so I might as well get it all off my mind.
一想到阿梅莉亚被卷入这场乱局，米勒就感到很不舒服。他要求单独待一会儿思考。他做出决定，只要接下来能让阿梅莉亚和沃雷尔置身事外，他就会开口。侦探同意了。米勒说：“我想无论事情怎么发展，我都已经没有什么好期待的了，所以我不如把这一切都从我脑子里卸下来。”
I guess I'm the one that got mixed up in all this, so where do you want me to start? The detective asked Miller if there were more bodies out there. Miller replied calmly. There are three more. Miller was given the choice of continuing with the false information or showing the detectives where the final three bodies were hidden. Miller replied,
“我想我是那个卷入这一切的人，所以你们想让我从哪里开始？”侦探问米勒外面是否还有更多尸体。米勒平静地回答：“还有三个。”米勒面临着两个选择：继续提供虚假信息，或者带侦探们去寻找最后三具尸体藏匿的地方。米勒回答说：
I think I'd rather show you where they are first and get it over with. That'll give me time to get my thoughts straight. By that point, the police had held Miller for six hours, which was the maximum time allowed without a formal charge being made. They couldn't hold him any longer without officially charging him for an offence. So, at 10.30pm, James Miller was charged with the murder of 15-year-old Conny Yordinates.
“我想我还是先带你们去看看它们在哪里，把事情了结了吧。这能让我有时间理清思绪。”此时，警方已经扣留了米勒六个小时，这是在未正式起诉情况下的最长法定滞留时间。在不正式起诉他罪名的情况下，他们不能再关押他了。于是，在晚上10点30分，詹姆斯·米勒被指控谋杀15岁的康妮·乔丹尼德斯（Conny Yordinates）。
The detectives found themselves in a conundrum. Now that Miller had been charged, South Australian law dictated that he either be given death penalty or death penalty, or death penalty, or death penalty, or death penalty, or death penalty,
侦探们发现自己陷入了一个两难境地。既然米勒已经被起诉，南澳大利亚法律规定，要么判处他死刑，要么死刑，或者死刑，或者死刑，或者死刑，或者死刑，
or death penalty, or death penalty, or death penalty, or death penalty, or death penalty, or death penalty, or death penalty, or death penalty,
或者死刑，或者死刑，或者死刑，或者死刑，或者死刑，或者死刑，或者死刑，或者死刑，
death penalty, or death penalty, or death penalty, or death penalty, or death penalty, or death penalty, or death penalty, or death penalty,
死刑，或者死刑，或者死刑，或者死刑，或者死刑，或者死刑，或者死刑，或者死刑，
waited until the morning when Miller could be put before a magistrate, he might change his mind and refuse to reveal where the other bodies were hidden. He would likely seek legal advice by then, and his lawyer would no doubt advise him to remain silent. Ultimately, the detectives decided the risk was worth it. If Miller could lead them to the bodies, not only would they have solid evidence to prove he was involved with the murders, they'd also have resolution for the victim's families. They had to trust that a judge would understand their predicament and support their decision. They led Miller into the back of a police car, and three detectives took him through the dark,
如果等到早上米勒被带到地方法官面前，他可能会改变主意，拒绝透露其他尸体藏在哪里。到那时他很可能会寻求法律咨询，他的律师无疑会建议他保持沉默。最终，侦探们认为这个风险是值得的。如果米勒能带他们找到尸体，他们不仅会有确凿的证据证明他参与了谋杀，还能给受害者家属一个交代。他们必须相信法官会理解他们的困境并支持他们的决定。他们将米勒带入警车后座，三名侦探带着他穿过阿德莱德黑暗、
cold streets of Adelaide and out towards Truro. A second police vehicle trailed behind, with officers prepared for the possibility that Miller might try to flee. They'd been given orders from the higher-ups to shoot him if he attempted to escape. On the contrary, Miller remained relaxed and calm the entire time. He chatted freely with the detectives, as though he was relieved to finally be getting this information off his chest. In fact, he was so cooperative that the detectives didn't bother placing him in handcuffs. They even stopped at a roadhouse and bought Miller cigarettes and baked goods. When they pulled into the outskirts of Truro, one of the detectives asked Miller if he
寒冷的街道，向特鲁罗方向开去。第二辆警车紧随其后，警员们做好了米勒可能试图逃跑的准备。他们接到了上级的命令，如果他企图逃跑就开枪击毙他。相反，米勒全程表现得轻松而平静。他与侦探们畅谈，仿佛如释重负，终于把这些信息吐露出来了。事实上，他非常配合，以至于侦探们都没有费心给他戴上手铐。他们甚至在一家路边小店停下来，给米勒买了两根香烟和烘焙食品。当车子开进特鲁罗郊区时，其中一名侦探问米勒他
could lead them to Julie Makita's body. Miller asked them to drive slowly. He led them down a dirt road about four and a half kilometers from where the bodies of Veronica, Sylvia, Connie and Vicki were found. It was on the opposite side of the Sturt Highway, an area that had been missed during the extensive search. Miller gazed carefully outside until he finally spotted a gate that led to an old abandoned farmhouse. He directed the detectives to drive towards it. They got out and Miller pointed towards a clump of trees in the middle of a paddock and said, I think it's over there. As they took out their torches and began to look,
能否带他们找到朱莉·马基塔（Julie Makita）的尸体。米勒要求他们慢慢开。他带着他们顺着一条土路走了大约四公里半，来到了发现维罗妮卡、西尔维娅、康妮和薇姬尸体的地方。它在斯特德公路（Sturt Highway）的另一侧，这是在密集搜查中被漏掉的一个区域。米勒仔细向外凝视，直到他终于发现了一个通往一个废弃老农舍的大门。他指示侦探们开车朝它驶去。他们下了车，米勒指着一块牧场中间的一丛树说：“我想它就在那边。”当他们拿出强光手电开始搜寻时，
it was clear that Miller was afraid. He surprised the detectives by asking them, don't leave me alone. The men were soon joined by about 20 other officers, but despite Miller's directions, they were unable to find Julie's body. The conditions were against them. It was pitch dark and freezing cold, with mist in the air and a layer of frost on the ground. All they had to go by was their torches and car headlights. After about an hour of searching, Miller recognized a familiar tree. He pointed towards it and hid an amongst the salt bush scrub, where the perfectly intact skeletal remains of Julie Makita. She was fully clothed, the money she'd earned from selling
很明显，米勒很害怕。他问侦探们“不要把我一个人留下”，这让侦探们大吃一惊。不久之后，大约有20名其他警员加入了他们的行列，但尽管有米勒的指引，他们还是没能找到朱莉的尸体。环境对他们极为不利。外面漆黑一片，天寒地冻，空气中弥漫着雾气，地面上一层薄霜。他们能依靠的只有手电筒和汽车前大灯。搜寻了一个多小时后，米勒认出了一棵熟悉的树。他指着它，藏身于咸蓬灌木丛中，朱莉·马基塔保存完好的白骨就躺在那里。她衣着完整，失踪当天靠卖
jewellery on the day she went missing still stuffed into the back pocket of her jeans. As one journalist described, quote, she was at rest, curled up like a cat against the cold. Miller told police the remaining two bodies weren't buried in the Truro area, but a little closer to the city. The first was in Port Gaula, an isolated tidal beach 42 kilometers north of Adelaide. Miller led the detectives down a dirt track to the sand, but couldn't find the location he was looking for. He had only visited the area once and wasn't familiar with the geography, especially in the dark. He directed them down another two dirt tracks, but the light from the torches was
珠宝赚来的钱还塞在牛仔裤的后口袋里。正如一位记者所描述的那样：“她安息着，像猫一样蜷缩着以抵御严寒。”米勒告诉警方，剩下的两具尸体没有埋在特鲁罗地区，而是离城市更近一些。第一具在加勒港（Port Gawla），一个位于阿德莱德以北42公里的偏远潮汐海滩。米勒引导侦探们沿着一条土路走到沙滩上，但找不到他要找的地方。他只去过那里一次，对那里的地理环境并不熟悉，尤其是在黑暗中。他引导他们沿着另外两条土路走，但手电筒的光
too dim and Miller became confused. After an hour of searching, the detectives decided to leave and come back at daylight. From there, Miller directed the detectives back towards the city to the outer northern suburb of Wingfield. They drove around for a while before Miller was able to pinpoint the correct road where he said the final body was buried under some shallow earth in a rifle shooting range. They got out and poked around, but Miller was unable to find the burial site. At 4am, the detectives finally decided to call it a night. They returned to both locations the following day. This time, Miller was able to locate the burial site in Wingfield. Excavators were used to dig through the sandy ground,
太暗了，米勒开始感到困惑。搜寻了一个小时后，侦探们决定离开，等天亮再回来。从那里，侦探们被米勒引导着返回城市，来到外北部郊区温菲尔德（Wingfield）。他们兜了一会儿圈子，直到米勒能够指出正确的道路，他说最后一具尸体就埋在射击靶场的一些浅土下面。他们下了车四处搜寻，但米勒无法找到埋葬地点。凌晨4点，侦探们终于决定收工。他们第二天重返这两个地点。这一次，米勒成功定位了温菲尔德的埋葬地点。挖掘机被用来挖掘沙地，
and eventually the remains of Tanya Kenny were uncovered. The second visit to Port Gaulah was more challenging due to Miller being unfamiliar with the location and the fact that there was very little to distinguish one area of the beach from another. A team of 50 investigators dug in multiple spots until they finally came across the seventh and final body. Found buried deep in a makeshift tomb of wood and corrugated iron were the remains of 20-year-old Deborah Lamb. Unlike the other six victims, Deborah's body was the only one that showed any evidence of violence. Her hands and feet were bound with a thin nylon rope, while a pair of pantyhose were stretched approximately six times around her jaw.
最终，塔尼娅·肯尼（Tanya Kenny）的遗骸被发掘出来。第二次访问加勒港更具挑战性，因为米勒对该地点不熟悉，而且海滩的一个区域与另一个区域没有什么区别。由50名调查人员组成的团队在多个地点进行挖掘，直到他们最终找到了第七具也是最后一具尸体。在用木头和波纹铁皮搭建的临时坟墓深处，发现了20岁的黛博拉·兰姆（Deborah Lamb）的遗骸。与其他六名受害者不同，黛博拉的尸体是唯一显示出暴力痕迹的尸体。她的手脚被一根细尼龙绳捆绑着，而一条连裤袜在她的下巴周围被拉伸了大约六次。
However, it wasn't strangulation that had killed her. Traces of sand found in Deborah's lungs indicated that she was still alive at the time she was buried. When investigators lifted Deborah's remains, they found a small heart-shaped badge underneath. It held an image of two children kissing and was inscribed with the words, God's only law is love. According to Miller, it all started on December 23, 1976. He and Warrell were cruising down King William Street when they spotted Veronica Knight at a bus stop near the Majestic Hotel. Warrell approached her and asked where she was going.
然而，杀死她的并不是勒死。黛博拉肺部发现的沙子痕迹表明，她被埋葬时仍然活着。当调查人员抬起黛博拉的遗骸时，他们在下面发现了一个小小的桃心徽章。上面印着两个孩子亲吻的图片，并刻着这样一句话：“上帝唯一的律法就是爱。”据米勒所说，这一切始于1976年12月23日。他和沃雷尔正沿着威廉国王街（King William Street）兜风，当时他们在雄伟酒店（Majestic Hotel）附近的公交车站发现了维罗妮卡·奈特。沃雷尔走近她，问她要去哪里。
She told them to the Salvation Army Hostel in the city and they offered to give her a ride. Veronica got in the back seat and when they took off, Warrell suggested that they go for a longer drive. For Miller, this was nothing unusual. He was used to Warrell picking up women this way and knew how it would go down. They'd drive to a quiet spot, he'd leave Warrell and Veronica alone and afterwards, they'd drop her at her destination. So when Veronica agreed, Miller knew what to expect. He drove towards the Adelaide Hills and eventually pulled over and got out of the car to give Warrell and Veronica some privacy. Miller then got back into the car and the trio decided to drive even
她告诉他们去市里的救世军收容所，他们主动提出载她一程。维罗妮卡上了后座，当他们开走时，沃雷尔建议他们去兜风远一点。对米勒来说，这没什么不寻常的。他习惯了沃雷尔用这种方式搭讪女性，并且知道事情会如何发展。他们会开车到一个安静的地方，他会把沃雷尔和维罗妮卡单独留在那里，事后，他们会把她送到目的地。所以当维罗妮卡同意时，米勒知道会发生什么。他朝阿德莱德山（Adelaide Hills）开去，最终把车停下并下了车，给沃雷尔和维罗妮卡一些隐私。随后米勒重新上了车，三人决定继续开车
further through the hills and out towards Truro. When they got there, it was late and pitch dark. Warrell directed Miller down a dirt track off the main road and told him to go for a walk on his own. Miller did as he was told, returning to the car about 20 minutes later. Warrell told him to bugger off so he trudged off into the darkness for another 20 minutes. This time, when he returned, everything was silent. Veronica's body was lifeless in the back seat. Miller panicked and asked what had happened. Warrell said he'd raped Veronica and then had to kill her to stop her from telling anyone. Given he was already on parole, another rape allegation meant he'd be given a long prison
继续深入丘陵，向特鲁罗方向驶去。当他们到达时，天色已晚且一片漆黑。沃雷尔指挥米勒驶离主路，拐进一条泥泞小路，并叫他独自去散步。米勒照做了，大约20分钟后回到了车里。沃雷尔叫他滚开，于是他踉踉跄跄地走进黑暗中又待了20分钟。这一次，当他回去时，四周一片死寂。维罗妮卡的尸体毫无生气地躺在后座上。米勒惊慌失措，问发生了什么事。沃雷尔说他强奸了维罗妮卡，然后不得不杀了她，以防她把事情说出去。鉴于他已经在假释期，再多一项强奸指控意味着他将被判处长期监禁。
sentence. Miller started freaking out, but Warrell told him it wasn't the first time this had happened. During his days serving in the Air Force, he had been stationed in Western Australia. On two separate occasions, he had picked up female hitchhikers and killed them. One of them had been a messy stabbing with the blood spurting everywhere. The other he had killed by bashing her head in with a rock. Miller wasn't sure whether or not to believe Warrell about the hitchhikers, but seeing what he had just done to Veronica, he was terrified. When Warrell demanded he help move Veronica's body, Miller was too scared to say no.
米勒开始吓得魂不附体，但沃雷尔告诉他，这已经不是第一次发生这种事了。在空军服役期间，他曾被派往西澳大利亚。在两个不同的场合，他曾搭载过女性搭车客并杀害了她们。其中一次是一次混乱的刺杀，鲜血四处飞溅。另一次他是用石头砸碎了受害者的头部将其杀害。米勒不确定是否该相信沃雷尔关于搭车客的说法，但看到他刚才对维罗妮卡做的事，他吓坏了。当沃雷尔要求他帮忙移动维罗妮卡的尸体时，米勒吓得根本不敢拒绝。
They struggled to lift her out of the car and into the paddock, but eventually managed to drag her over the fence and dump her body under some bushes. On the drive home, Warrell was clearly deep in one of his dark moods. Miller believed Veronica's murder was a freak occurrence that would never happen again. They went about their daily lives like nothing had happened, returning to work the following morning and carrying on their usual routine of driving around at night and picking up women without any other incidents. One week later, on the morning of December 31, 1976, Warrell asked Miller to drop him off on King William Street so he could go for a walk through Rundlemore. It was no surprise to Miller
他们费了好大劲才把她从车里抬出来弄到牧场里，但最终设法把她拖过栅栏，扔在了一些灌木丛下。在回家的路上，沃雷尔显然陷入了某种阴暗的情绪中。米勒相信维罗妮卡的谋杀是一次离奇的意外，绝不会再次发生。他们像什么也没发生一样过着日常生活，第二天早上照常上班，继续他们夜间开车闲逛、搭载女性的日常习惯，没有发生其他事故。一周后，即1976年12月31日早晨，沃雷尔让米勒把他放在威廉国王街，这样他就可以穿过兰德尔莫尔散步。米勒并不感到意外
that when they met up again shortly after, Warrell had a pretty teenage girl with him. Her name was Tanya Kenny. She had just returned from her New Year's Eve getaway down the south coast and agreed to let Warrell and Miller drop her home. Warrell said they just needed to stop at Miller's sister's vacant house in the western suburbs to grab a few things on their way. Miller's sister was in the process of moving out and needed him to gather up his old things. Tanya agreed and when they arrived there, Warrell asked Tanya to help him out inside. He told Miller to wait in the car, so Miller parked in the driveway and waited patiently.
当他们不久后再次碰面时，沃雷尔身边带着一个漂亮的妙龄少女。她叫坦娅·肯尼。她刚刚结束了南海岸的跨年夜假期，同意让沃雷尔和米勒顺路送她回家。沃雷尔说，他们中途只需要在米勒位于西区空置的姐姐家里停一下，拿几样东西。米勒的姐姐正在搬家，需要他去收拾他的旧东西。坦娅同意了，当他们到达那里时，沃雷尔请坦娅进去帮个忙。他叫米勒在车里等着，于是米勒把车停在车道上，耐心地等待着。
After some time, Warrell came out of the house alone. Miller could tell something was wrong by the look on his face and quickly raced inside. In his old bedroom, he found Tanya lying on the floor with her hands and feet bound together. A piece of tape was stuck over her mouth and there was a wound around her neck. Miller started screaming at Warrell, who threatened to kill Miller too if he didn't shut up. Miller was desperate to get Tanya's body out of the house before his sister found out, but it was broad daylight, so they hid her in the bedroom cupboard and spent the next few hours driving around looking for a suitable place to dispose of her body. They eventually decided on a paddock in the Dean rifle range in Wingfield
过了一会儿，沃雷尔独自一人从房子里走了出来。从他的脸色，米勒看出不对劲，急忙冲进了屋里。在他的旧卧室里，他发现坦娅躺在地板上，手脚被绑在一起。她的嘴上贴着一块胶带，脖子上有一处伤口。米勒开始对沃雷尔尖叫，沃雷尔威胁说如果米勒不闭嘴，也要杀了他。米勒迫切地想在姐姐发现之前把坦娅的尸体弄出房子，但当时是大白天，于是他们把她藏在卧室的衣柜里，在接下来的几个小时里开车四处寻找合适的地方来处理她的尸体。他们最终选定了温菲尔德迪恩靶场的一个牧场，
and dug a hole in preparation for the burial. They returned to Miller's sister's house at night, loaded Tanya's body into the boot of the car and then buried her in the makeshift grave. After Tanya's murder, Miller lived in fear that Warrell would strike once more. He tried to deny what was happening, blaming Warrell's dark moods and telling himself it wouldn't happen again. Weeks passed without incident until January 21, 1977, when the pair were driving down King William Street. They spotted Julie Makeda waiting for a bus outside the ambassador's hotel and Warrell got out of the car to chat her up. He eventually convinced her to go for a drive with them and the trio headed out to the northern suburb of Jepps Cross,
并挖了一个洞准备埋葬。他们于夜间回到米勒姐姐的家，把坦娅的尸体装进汽车后备箱，然后将她埋在临时坟墓里。坦娅被害后，米勒生活在恐惧之中，害怕沃雷尔会再次下手。他试图否认正在发生的事情，将之归咎于沃雷尔阴暗的情绪，并告诉自己不会再发生了。几个星期过去了，相安无事，直到1977年1月21日，两人正沿着威廉国王街开车。他们发现朱莉·马凯达正在大使酒店外面等公交车，沃雷尔下车去搭讪她。他最终说服她搭他们的车兜风，三人前往北郊杰普斯克罗斯，
where they parked down a side street. There, Warrell tied Julie up, telling her it would be a bit of fun. They then drove a further 80 kilometers out to Truro, where Miller left Warrell and Julie alone. All he could do was hope that Warrell didn't enter one of his dark moods. When Miller returned to the car, Warrell had convinced Julie to walk out into the paddock. He told Miller to wait in the car, but he didn't listen and followed them instead. Miller heard a loud noise through the darkness and thought Warrell must have kicked Julie in the stomach. Fearing what was about to happen, Miller stepped in, but Warrell threatened to kill him if he tried to intervene. Warrell then strangled Julie and Miller reluctantly helped him cover
把车停在了一条小巷里。在那里，沃雷尔把朱莉绑了起来，告诉她这会挺有意思的。然后他们又向特鲁罗方向开去了80公里，米勒在那里把沃雷尔和朱莉留下了。他能做的只有祈祷沃雷尔不要陷入他那阴暗的情绪中。当米勒回到车里时，沃雷尔已经说服朱莉走到牧场里去了。他让米勒在车里等，但米勒没有听，而是跟了上去。米勒在黑暗中听到一声巨响，心想沃雷尔一定是踢了朱莉的肚子。由于害怕即将发生的事情，米勒介入了，但沃雷尔威胁说，如果他敢插手，就要杀了他。接着沃雷尔勒死了朱莉，米勒很不情愿地帮他掩盖了
her body up with bushes. A little over two weeks later, on February 6th, Warrell started chatting with Sylvia Pittman and once again used his charm to convince her to go for a drive with them. They headed out to Truro, where Miller went on one of his usual lone walks. When he returned 45 minutes later, Warrell was alone. Miller asked where Sylvia had gone and Warrell replied, don't worry about it. The following day, Warrell met Vicki Howell in the city and struck up a conversation. She agreed to go for a drive with him out to the Barossa Valley wine region, so Miller came and picked them up. Miller liked Vicki immediately. She was older than the women Warrell usually picked up and he found her to be very ladylike. They went for a drive out
用灌木丛盖住了她的尸体。两周多一点后，即2月6日，沃雷尔开始与西尔维娅·皮特曼交谈，并再次用他的魅力说服她搭他们的车兜风。他们前往特鲁罗，米勒在那里进行了他例行的独自散步。45分钟后他回来时，沃雷尔独自一人。米勒问西尔维娅去哪了，沃雷尔回答说，不用担心。第二天，沃雷尔在城里遇到了维基·豪威尔并搭话。她同意跟他一起去巴罗萨谷葡萄酒产区兜风，于是米勒开车来接他们。米勒一眼就喜欢上了维基。她比沃雷尔通常接载的女性年龄要大，他觉得她非常淑女。他们开车向
towards Truro, stopping at one point so that Vicki could go to the toilet. After that, Miller claimed he couldn't remember what happened. He assumed Warrell had done to Vicki what he did to the others, but he had no memory of the incident. He told the detectives, I liked her and I wouldn't have let Chris do anything to her if I had known. Two days later, on February 9, the two men were driving down King William Street when they pulled over on the side of the road. Connie Yordanides was waiting at a bus stop and started chatting with Warrell through the open window. She said she was on her way to pick up a package in the northern suburbs. Warrell offered her a lift and she agreed to go for a drive with them.
特鲁罗方向驶去，中途停了一次，以便维基去洗手间。在那之后，米勒声称他不记得发生了什么。他猜测沃雷尔对维基做了他对其他人做的事，但他对这起事件没有任何记忆。他告诉侦探们：“我喜欢她，如果我知道的话，我不会让克里斯对她做任何事的。”两天后的2月9日，两人正沿着威廉国王街开车，突然把车停在了路边。康妮·约丹尼德斯正在公交车站等车，隔着摇下的车窗跟沃雷尔聊了起来。她说她正要去北郊取个包裹。沃雷尔主动提出载她一程，她同意搭他们的车。
They headed out to Truro, where Miller left them alone in the back seat. When he returned, the three of them started driving back towards Adelaide, but Warrell asked him to pull over again down a side road. Miller left them alone and went for a walk, and when he returned, Warrell was alone. Miller said he didn't want to know about what had happened, to which Warrell remarked that Connie would have made a great girlfriend. A couple of days later, Miller and Warrell were driving down Hindley Street in Adelaide CBD when they met Deborah Lamb. She accepted Warrell's offer of a lift and the trio drove out to Port Gawler, where Warrell asked Miller to go for a walk.
他们向特鲁罗驶去，米勒把他们独自留在后座上。当他回来时，他们三个人开始往阿德莱德方向开回去，但沃雷尔让他把车停在另一条小巷里。米勒留下他们自己去散步了，等他回来时，沃雷尔独自一人。米勒说他不想知道发生了什么，沃雷尔对此评论说，康妮本可以成为一个很好的女朋友。几天后，米勒和沃雷尔正开着车穿过阿德莱德市中心的欣德利街时，遇到了黛博拉·兰姆。她接受了沃雷尔搭车的邀请，三人驱车前往高勒港，沃雷尔在那里让米勒去散步。
He returned 30 minutes later and found Warrell burying Deborah's body in the sand. It was clear he had entered a very dark mood, refusing to say a word about what had happened. Miller was terrified about the frequency at which Warrell was now killing his victims and was scared about what would happen next, but he didn't have to wait long. One week later, the fatal car accident occurred and Chris Warrell was dead, putting an end to the crime spree. As Miller confessed to one murder after the next, the interviewing detectives couldn't believe what they were hearing. One asked Miller why he had helped Warrell instead of trying to stop him. Miller replied, I don't know. We'd picked up girls before and nothing happened. I couldn't
他30分钟后回来，发现沃雷尔正在沙子里埋葬黛博拉的尸体。很明显，他陷入了一种非常阴暗的情绪中，对发生的事情闭口不谈。米勒对沃雷尔现在杀害受害者的频率感到恐惧，也害怕接下来会发生什么，但他并没有等太久。一周后，致命的车祸发生了，克里斯·沃雷尔死了，这场犯罪狂潮也就此画上了句号。当米勒一桩接一桩地供认谋杀时，正在进行讯问的侦探们简直不敢相信自己的耳朵。其中一人问米勒，他为什么帮沃雷尔而不是试图阻止他。米勒回答说：“我不知道。我们以前接载过女孩，什么也没发生。我在不危及自己的情况下做不了
do much without endangering myself, and I really believe that. Much to his dismay, James Miller was charged with all seven murders. While he understood that he had to face some kind of repercussion for not stopping the killings or reporting the crimes earlier, he didn't believe he should be charged for the murders themselves. He staunchly maintained that he had no part in any of the killings and was, quote, just the chauffeur and the mug. As 1979 drew to an end, preparations were in place for James Miller's trial. There were fears that the decision to interrogate Miller and take him to the burial sites before he had the chance to
太多，我是真的这么认为的。”令他沮丧的是，詹姆斯·米勒被指控犯有全部七起谋杀罪。虽然他明白自己没有阻止杀戮或更早报案，必须面对某种惩罚，但他认为自己不应该被指控谋杀罪本身。他坚定地坚称自己没有参与任何杀戮，而且用他的话来说，“只是个司机和冤大头”。随着1979年接近尾声，詹姆斯·米勒的审判筹备工作正在进行。人们担心，在米勒有机会
seek legal advice could harm the case against him. Because of this decision, it was possible that a judge might refuse to allow into evidence the 16 hours of police questioning during which Miller admitted to the crimes and provided his version of events. Without this, due to the lack of forensic evidence to indicate where or how the victims had died, there would be very little for the prosecution to present to a jury. However, the judge allowed this evidence to be admitted, and Miller's trial commenced in Adelaide's Supreme Court on February 12, 1980, exactly three years to the day since the last victim, Deborah Lamb, was last seen. Curious members of the press and public competed for a spot in the courtroom, with one reporter labelling it a, quote, raffle ticket drama. A security guard
寻求法律咨询之前，对他进行讯问并带他去埋尸地点的决定可能会损害针对他的指控。由于这个决定，法官可能会拒绝将米勒承认罪行并陈述其版本经过的16小时警方讯问作为证据采纳。如果没有这些，由于缺乏表明受害者在何处或如何死亡的法医证据，检方在陪审团面前将拿不出什么实质证据。然而，法官允许采纳这些证据，米勒的审判于1980年2月12日在阿德莱德最高法院开庭，正好是最后一个受害者黛博拉·兰姆失踪满三年的那一天。好奇的媒体成员和公众争夺法庭旁听席位，一名记者将其称为“抽奖券式的戏剧”。一名保安
was on standby to keep spectators in order, while James Miller sat behind a low iron fence with a bored expression on his face. The prosecution set out to prove that the murders were an equally joint enterprise between Chris Worrell and James Miller. Their case relied heavily on Miller's confessions to both police and Worrell's ex-girlfriend Amelia, who was a reluctant witness. On the stand, Amelia hesitantly explained that the reason she never came forward was that she believed the state was looking for a scapegoat. Had she dogged Miller in, he could be blamed for not only the Truro murders, but potentially any other unsolved crimes. She told the court, Miller convinced me that he was virtually the innocent one, and that Chris was the guilty one.
在旁听席严阵以待以维持秩序，而詹姆斯·米勒则神情厌倦地坐在矮铁栏杆后面。控方着手证明这些谋杀案是克里斯·沃勒尔和詹姆斯·米勒共同密谋的罪行。他们的案子在很大程度上依赖于米勒向警方以及沃勒尔的不情愿的证人前女友阿梅利亚的供词。在证人席上，阿梅利亚犹豫不决地解释说，她从未站出来的原因是她相信国家正在寻找替罪羊。如果她把米勒供出来，他不仅可能被指控犯有特鲁罗谋杀案，还可能被指控犯有任何其他未破的罪行。她对法庭说：“米勒说服我，他几乎是无辜的，而克里斯才是那个有罪的人。”
If I did go to the police, then I thought I would be dobbing in an innocent man, because I thought the guilty one was dead. It was only when Amelia was confronted by police that she learned the truth about Worrell and Miller's criminal histories, and realized that Miller might not be as innocent as he led her to believe. For the defense, Miller opted to prepare an unsworn statement for the court. It was a controversial decision. An unsworn statement is where an accused presents their version of events without having to swear under oath, and it isn't subject to cross-examination. No further questions can be asked by members of the court, and the accused isn't required to elaborate on any of the details.
“如果我真的去报警，那我以为我会出卖一个无辜的人，因为我以为有罪的人已经死了。”直到阿梅利亚面对警方质问时，她才了解到沃勒尔和米勒犯罪历史的真相，并意识到米勒可能并不像他引导自己相信的那样无辜。对于辩护方，米勒选择为法庭准备一份未经宣誓的陈述。这是一个颇具争议的决定。未经宣誓的陈述是指被告在不必宣誓的情况下陈述他们对事件版本的看法，并且不受交叉盘问。法庭成员不能再提出进一步的问题，被告也不需要阐述任何细节。
By choosing this option, it meant that Miller's entire case relied on his own statement. The jury were advised by the judge to scrutinize Miller's version of events carefully, before deciding what weight should be attributed to it. Standing before the court, it took Miller close to an hour to deliver his 50-page version of the seven murders in detail. This description differed to the confession he provided to police after his arrest. Whereas Miller initially told the detectives that Worrell had raped the seven victims prior to strangling them, he now said this wasn't the case. He claimed the women had consensual sex with Worrell and let him tie them up,
通过选择这个选项，这意味着米勒的整个辩护都依赖于他自己的陈述。法官建议陪审团仔细审查米勒的事件版本，然后再决定应赋予其多大的分量。站在法庭前，米勒花了将近一个小时详细讲述了他对七起谋杀案的50页版本。这番描述与他被捕后向警方提供的口供有所不同。虽然米勒最初告诉侦探，沃勒尔在勒死七名受害者之前强奸了她们，但他现在改口说并非如此。他声称这些女性与沃勒尔发生了自愿性行为，并让他把自己绑起来，
before Worrell entered his dark moods and made the snap decision to kill them. Miller also added in additional details, including that after Worrell killed Veronica Knight, he threatened Miller at knife point, forcing him to help move her body and warning him not to say a word to anyone about what had happened. It was because of this that Miller feared for his life and continued to be complicit to the following murders. Miller also claimed to have lied when telling police that five of the murders had happened at Truro. He clarified that they had been killed closer to Adelaide and he and Worrell had then driven out to Truro to dump the bodies. Miller declared,
然后沃勒尔陷入阴暗情绪，做出杀死她们的突发决定。米勒还补充了更多细节，包括沃勒尔杀死维罗妮卡·奈特后，用刀威胁米勒，逼迫他帮忙搬运尸体，并警告他不准向任何人透露发生了什么。正因为如此，米勒才感到生命受到威胁，并在之后的谋杀中继续同谋。米勒还声称，他此前告诉警方其中五起谋杀案发生在特鲁罗是在撒谎。他澄清说，她们是在离阿德莱德更近的地方被杀害的，他和沃勒尔随后开车去特鲁罗抛尸。米勒宣称：
I admit that I helped dispose of the bodies and I admit that I was with Worrell before the girls were murdered, but I certainly did not think they were going to be killed and I certainly did not take part or help in their killing at all. I realize I have behaved very weakly and badly in not physically stopping Worrell and not reporting the matter to the police as soon as the first death occurred. By not telling the police about Worrell, I am probably guilty of some offence, but I am not guilty of murder because I did not want any of these girls to die. On each occasion, I was horrified and frightened. Miller's defense lawyer warned the jury against using Miller as a scapegoat for Chris Worrell's
“我承认我帮忙处理了尸体，我也承认在女孩被谋杀之前我和沃勒尔在一起，但我绝对没有想到她们会被杀，而且我绝对没有参与或协助她们的谋杀。”我意识到自己在没有实体阻止沃勒尔以及在第一起命案发生后没有立即报警这件事上表现得非常软弱和糟糕。由于没有向警方举报沃勒尔，我可能犯了某种罪行，但我没有犯谋杀罪，因为我不想让这些女孩中的任何一个死去。在每一个场合，我都感到惊恐和害怕。米勒的辩护律师警告陪审团，不要把米勒当作克里斯·沃勒尔罪行的替罪羊。
crimes. He reminded them that Miller wasn't being charged with being an accessory to murder or helping to dispose of the bodies, but that he was being accused of the murders themselves. For them to find Miller guilty, they had to be certain he had agreed with Worrell to commit the murders or was present when Worrell strangled his victims and encouraged the behavior. In defense of Miller not reporting Worrell's crimes and continuing to help him dispose of the bodies, his lawyer explained. Through contact with Worrell, the accused stumbled into Worrell's problems. None of them is the accused's own making, but because of circumstances and Worrell's demands, the accused helps dispose of the first body and from then on is involved. Whether he likes it or
他提醒他们，米勒受到的指控不是谋杀从犯或协助处理尸体，而是谋杀罪本身。要判定米勒有罪，他们必须确信他曾同意与沃勒尔一起实施谋杀，或者在沃勒尔勒死受害者时在场并助长这种行为。为了辩护米勒为何没有举报沃勒尔的罪行并继续帮他处理尸体，他的律师解释道：通过与沃勒尔的接触，被告误打误撞地卷入了沃勒尔的麻烦中。这些都不是被告自己造成的，但由于环境和沃勒尔的要求，被告帮忙处理了第一具尸体，从那时起就卷入其中了。不管他愿不愿意
not, he is involved and he is left with little choice about the second body because that is in his sister's house. From then on, he is on the tiger's back. He cannot get off. In closing arguments, the prosecution stated that no man would accompany a rapist on seven expeditions unless he had at least a sexual interest in what was happening, even if it was only as an onlooker. They told the jury, ultimately it does not matter if that is the one reason why Miller went along or not. His role as the joint picker-upper, the driver, the body disposer, that of course is enough to render him liable in the eyes of the law to murder if there was this understanding in arrangement between him and Worrell to that end or alternatively if he realized
不，他已经卷入其中，对于第二具尸体他几乎没有选择，因为那是在他姐姐的家里。从那时起，他骑虎难下，无法脱身。在结案陈词中，控方陈述说，没有哪个男人会陪着一个强奸犯经历七次远征，除非他对正在发生的事情至少有某种性趣，哪怕只是作为一个旁观者。他们告诉陪审团：“归根结底，米勒同行是否出于这唯一的原因其实并不重要。他作为共同物色者、司机、抛尸者的角色，如果他和沃勒尔之间存在这种理解和安排，或者换句话说，如果他意识到了”
Worrell's game and played that part in it. The prosecutor continued, you might think that the evidence suggests Miller was so besotted with Worrell that he would stop at nothing and did stop at nothing, not even involvement in seven murders. Maybe Worrell did have a stronger personality than the accused. Maybe he was the only true friend he ever had. The simple answer to that is, so what? It might explain why seven girls were done to death. It doesn't excuse it. The judge clarified to the jury that if they accepted Miller's story that Worrell was solely responsible for the killings, they had to decide whether it was reasonable to assume that Miller knew that Worrell was going to kill his victims and did nothing to stop him. He used a robbery
沃勒尔的游戏并在其中扮演了那个角色，在法律眼中，这当然足以让他承担谋杀罪的责任。检察官继续说道：“你可能会认为证据表明米勒对沃勒尔如此迷恋，以至于他会不惜一切代价，也确实不惜一切代价，甚至不惜卷入七起谋杀案。也许沃勒尔的性格确实比被告更强。也许他曾是沃勒尔唯一的真朋友。对此最简单的回答是：那又怎样？这或许可以解释为什么七个女孩惨遭杀害，但这并不能成为借口。”法官向陪审团澄清，如果他们接受米勒的说法，即沃勒尔对谋杀负全责，他们就必须决定，假设米勒知道沃勒尔要杀害受害者却什么也没阻止，这种假设是否合理。他用三名男子犯下的抢劫案
committed by three men as an example. If one man stays in the car, one keeps a look out at the door and one enters the house to steal the belongings, all three of them are guilty of robbery because they were all involved in the plan and all knew what was going to happen. Had the man who entered the home unexpectedly come upon the owner and killed them, he would be guilty of murder while his other two accomplices would not because they hadn't agreed with this part of the plan. On March 11, the jury deliberated for eight hours before returning their verdict. For the murders of Sylvia Pittman, Julie Makeda, Vicki Howe, Connie Yordanides, Tanya Kenney, and Deborah Lamb, James Miller was declared guilty. However, he was found not guilty
作为例子。如果一个人留在车里，一人在门口把风，一人进屋偷东西，这三人都犯了抢劫罪，因为他们都参与了计划并且都知道会发生什么。如果进屋的那个人意外遇到了房主并杀害了他们，他将犯有谋杀罪，而他的另外两个同伙则不会，因为他们没有同意计划的这一部分。3月11日，陪审团商议了八个小时后做出了裁决。关于对西尔维娅·皮特曼、朱莉·马凯达、维基·豪、康妮·约丹尼德斯、坦娅·肯尼和黛博拉·兰姆的谋杀罪，詹姆斯·米勒被宣告有罪。然而，他被判无罪
for the murder of the first victim, Veronica Knight, as the jury believed it was plausible that Miller genuinely didn't know that Worrell was going to kill her. James Miller was sentenced to serve six consecutive life sentences with a non-parole period of 35 years. He lurched forward over the guardrail and yelled at one of the detectives, quote, you filthy liar, you mongrel. Miller's sister echoed his statement, screaming, you laughing swine. Two prison wardens grabbed hold of Miller and pushed him out the side door and into the holding cells, while another woman in the public gallery turned to the judge and yelled, you are just as guilty for letting Worrell out on parole. Miller was sent back to Yatla Prison, this time
对于谋杀第一名受害者维罗妮卡·奈特的指控，因为陪审团认为米勒确实不知道沃勒尔会杀害她，这种说法是合理的。詹姆斯·米勒被判处六个连续终身监禁，不得假释期为35岁。他猛地向前扑过护栏，对其中一名侦探大喊：“你这个肮脏的骗子，你这个杂种。”米勒的姐姐呼应了他的话，尖叫着：“你们这群幸灾乐祸的猪。”两名狱警抓住米勒，把他推侧门推进了拘留室，而旁听席上的另一名妇女则转向法官大喊：“放沃勒尔假释出狱，你同样有罪。”米勒被送回亚特拉监狱，这一次
without his blood brother by his side. Very few believe that James Miller was merely a bystander to his best friend's crimes. Whether or not he assisted in the killings remains a mystery, but at the very least, he actively facilitated them. Had Chris Worrell not been killed in the car accident at the peak of his crime spree, experts believe there would have most certainly been more victims. Professor of criminology, Paul Wilson, said, serial killers don't stop unless they are caught. I have never heard of therapy or anything else stopping serial killers. They may be very sociopathic, but they are not insane. Even James Miller agreed. He predicted that if Worrell had survived, there could have been
没有他的好兄弟陪在身边。很少有人相信詹姆斯·米勒仅仅是他最好朋友罪行的旁观者。他是否协助了这些谋杀仍然是个谜，但至少，他积极地促成了这些谋杀。如果克里斯·沃勒尔没有在他犯罪狂潮的巅峰时期在车祸中丧生，专家们相信，几乎肯定会有更多的受害者。犯罪学教授保罗·威尔逊说：“连环杀手不被抓获是不会收手的。我从未听说过治疗或其他什么方法能阻止连环杀手。他们可能非常反社会，但他们并不疯狂。”就连詹姆斯·米勒也表示赞同。他预测，如果沃勒尔幸存下来，受害者可能会
up to 70 victims, and he would never have doped him in. It remains unclear whether Worrell's claims that he murdered two hitchhikers in Western Australia were ever investigated. James Miller tried to appeal his conviction and argue for a retrial, but his attempts were unsuccessful. In 1984, he went on a 43-day hunger strike in protest against his conviction, but it didn't pay off. The following year, with the help of writer Dick Wordly, Miller published a book titled Don't Call Me Killer, which gave his detailed first-person account of his relationship with Chris Worrell and the Truro Murders. In the book, Miller staunchly stood by the version of events he gave in his unsworn statement. He made it sound like all seven
高达70人，而且他绝不会出卖他。目前尚不清楚沃勒尔声称自己在西澳大利亚杀害了两名搭车客的说法是否曾受到调查。詹姆斯·米勒试图对自己的定罪提出上诉并争取重审，但他的尝试没有成功。1984年，他进行了为期43天的绝食抗议，抗议自己的定罪，但这并没有奏效。第二年，在作家迪克·沃德利的帮助下，米勒出版了一本名为《别叫我杀手》的书，详细记录了第一人称视角下他与克里斯·沃勒尔的关系以及特鲁罗谋杀案。在这本书中，米勒坚定地坚持了他在未经宣誓的陈述中给出的事件版本。他把这一切说得好像所有七名
women happily consented to sex and bondage with Worrell, as though they were lucky to be chosen by him. In reality, the women had likely accepted a lift from the charming Worrell, feeling a false sense of security in his lie that Miller was his father or uncle. Once they were inside the car, there was little they could do as Worrell forced himself on them and launched a brutal attack, either with or without the help of his sidekick. In the final passage of the book, Miller wrote, If the blame for Truro should be pointed at any one particular person, then I feel it should be pointed at me. Chris had no control over his dark moods, and I knew that he must have had a serious
女性都幸福地同意与沃勒尔发生性行为和施虐受虐，就好像她们很幸运被他选中一样。现实中，这些女性很可能接受了迷人的沃勒尔的搭车邀请，因为沃勒尔谎称米勒是他的父亲或叔叔，这让她们产生了一种虚假的安全感。一旦她们上了车，面对沃勒尔强行施暴并展开残忍袭击（无论是否有其同伙的协助），她们也无能为力。在书的最后一段，米勒写道：“如果特鲁罗的责备应该指向某一个特定的人，那么我觉得应该指向我。克里斯无法控制他阴暗的情绪，我知道他一定有严重的问题，”
problem, and I should have done something positive about it to help him after the first murder, and I do not mean by helping him to dispose of the body. Somehow, I should have made sure that the person I loved more than anyone else received medical attention, but I did not. Thus, I must accept my guilt. One Chris Worrell was a killer. One Chris Worrell was a young man with a sickness he could not control. That Chris Worrell appeared in the courts. That Chris Worrell could have been cured of his sickness. That Chris Worrell was Truro. Another, the real Chris Worrell was not a killer. The real Chris Worrell was a happy-go-lucky, easy-going, friendly, considerate, sincere, and utterly appealing humane and beautiful young man who any parent would be proud to have
并且在第一起谋杀发生后，我本该采取积极的措施来帮助他，我指的不是帮他处理尸体。不知怎的，我本该确保那个我比任何人都要爱的人得到医疗救助，但我没有。因此，我必须承认我的罪责。一个克里斯·沃勒尔是个杀手。一个克里斯·沃勒尔是一个患有他无法控制的疾病的年轻人。那个克里斯·沃勒尔出现在法庭上。那个克里斯·沃勒尔本可以治愈他的疾病。那个克里斯·沃勒尔就是特鲁罗。另一个，真正的克里斯·沃勒尔不是个杀手。真正的克里斯·沃勒尔是一个无忧无虑、随和、友善、体贴、真诚、极其迷人且有人情美德的年轻男子，任何父母都会为有他这样的儿子而感到骄傲，正如我为拥有他作为我最亲爱的朋友而感到骄傲一样。
as a son, as I was proud to have him as my dearest friend. Seven years after his death, I find that I still love him, despite the cost. Miller was due for parole in 2014, but in 2007 his health took a rapid decline. He was diagnosed with lung cancer and prostate cancer and suffered from ongoing complications caused by Hepatitis C. On October 21, 2008, James Miller passed away in hospital from liver failure at the age of 68. In the wake of the Truro murders, the parole board's decision to release Chris Worrell after he'd served just two years of his six-year prison sentence for rape was strongly criticised. The truth of his rape conviction was that he'd picked up a female hitchhiker,
在他死后七年，我发现我依然爱着他，无论付出什么代价。米勒本应在2014年获得假释，但在2007年，他的健康状况急剧恶化。他被诊断出患有肺癌和前列腺癌，并饱受丙型肝炎引起的持续并发症的折磨。2008年10月21日，詹姆斯·米勒因肝衰竭在医院去世，享年68岁。特鲁罗谋杀案发生后，假释委员会决定在克里斯·沃勒尔因强奸罪被判处六年监禁仅服刑两年后就将其释放，这一决定受到了强烈的批评。他强奸定罪的真相是，他搭载了一名女性搭车客，
driven her out to a sports oval, and attempted to rape her at Knife Point. He'd been unsuccessful and eventually let her go after she promised she wouldn't tell anyone what had happened. Had Worrell been forced to serve his entire sentence, the lives of the seven young women could have been spared. The decision haunted Worrell's parole officer for years, even though he had followed the rules by the book. As part of Worrell receiving parole, he had to undergo a psychiatric evaluation. In hindsight, it served as an ominous warning, declaring, quote, Christopher Worrell denied having committed rape and told a good story of how he had been framed. He came across as presenting the picture he felt would most impress,
把她带到一个运动场，并试图持刀强奸她。他没有得逞，最终在受害者承诺不将发生的事情告诉任何人后放了她。如果沃勒尔被迫服满全部刑期，七名年轻女性的生命本可以免于涂炭。这个决定困扰了沃勒尔的假释官多年，尽管他是按规定按部就班地行事的。作为沃勒尔获得假释的一部分，他必须接受精神病学评估。事后看来，这起到了一个不祥的警告作用，其中写道：“克里斯托弗·沃勒尔否认自己曾犯下强奸罪，并编造了一个关于自己如何被陷害的好故事。他给人的印象是他觉得最能留下深刻印象的形象，”
and one did not feel there was much sincerity in his protestations of future innocence. However, there is no history of convictions before the age of 20 years, and the circumstances of his rape offence made it inevitable that he was caught. One wonders if he was going through a temporary phase of readjustment at the time. Only the future will tell. Chris Worrell is buried in Adelaide Centennial Park Cemetery. His gravestone reads, Untold Love and Joy He Brought to War In 1997, 22-year-old Nikki was curious to learn more about her family history.
并且人们感觉不到他对未来清白的抗议有多少真诚。然而，他20岁之前没有犯罪记录，而且其强奸罪行的特殊环境使得他被抓是不可避免的。人们不禁好奇，他当时是否正经历一个暂时的重新适应阶段。只有未来才会给出答案。克里斯·沃勒尔被安葬在阿德莱德百年公园公墓。他的墓碑上写着：“他带给战争无尽的爱与喜悦”1997年，22岁的尼基对了解更多家族历史产生了好奇。
Nikki had been adopted when she was six months old and felt it was finally time to find out who her biological parents were. She contacted the relevant authorities, and when she walked into her scheduled meeting, the staff member said, You're the baby from the picture in the papers. That's how Nikki learned that Deborah Lamb, Worrell and Miller's seventh victim, had been her birth mother. When Deborah's body had been discovered, a photo of her holding baby Nikki had been used by the press. It would now be the only photo Nikki would ever have of her biological mother. As a teenager growing up in Adelaide, Nikki and her friends had been warned not to get into cars with strangers, or they'd end up, quote, like the Truro girls.
尼基在六个月大时就被收养了，她觉得是时候找出自己的亲生父母是谁了。她联系了相关部门，当她走进预约好的会议时，工作人员说：“你就是报纸照片上的那个婴儿。”尼基就是这样得知黛博拉·兰姆——沃勒尔和米勒的第七名受害者——是她的亲生母亲。当黛博拉的尸体被发现时，媒体使用了她抱着婴儿尼基的照片。现在这将成为尼基唯一能拥有的亲生母亲的照片。作为在阿德莱德长大的青少年，尼基和她的朋友们曾被警告不要上陌生人的车，否则她们就会落得个“像特鲁罗女孩那样”的下场。
It was unbelievable to Nikki to know that her mother had been one of those girls. She felt robbed of getting to know her biological mother, but believed that Deborah would have been proud of the warm and loving upbringing Nikki received from her adoptive parents. She told Woman's Day magazine, For six months, she did one hell of a job trying to raise me by herself before she gave me up so I could have a better life. In the wake of James Miller's trial, the advertiser published an editorial that deeply upset the loved ones of the victims. It read, It is clearly the duty of the parents of the girls, particularly the naive, the gullible, and the misguidedly adventurous, to impress upon them the dangers
对尼基来说，得知自己的母亲就是那些女孩中的一员，简直让人难以置信。她觉得自己被剥夺了了解亲生母亲的机会，但她相信，黛博拉会为尼基从养父母那里得到的温暖而充满爱意的抚养感到骄傲。她对《妇女周刊》杂志说：“在把我送人以让我过上更好的生活之前，她独自一人极其艰难地试图抚养我六个月。”在詹姆斯·米勒审判之后，《广告人报》发表了一篇社论，深深地伤害了受害者亲属的心。社论写道：“这显然是女孩父母的职责，尤其是那些天真、易受骗和盲目冒险的女孩父母，去向她们灌输危险意识”
of walking alone in the streets at night, and accepting lifts in cars, and the fact that accepting lifts in cars offered by people unknown to them. Girls who tend to be free with their favours, are committing no offence by behaving as they choose, but they must realise that in doing so, they are exposing themselves to mortal danger. Ann Marie Makita was appalled. Not only did the article place the blame on the victims for what happened to them, but the young women weren't free with their favours, or roaming the streets recklessly as the article suggested. They were simply out living their lives. Several of the abductions occurred in broad daylight,
独自在夜间街头行走以及接受搭便车的事实，以及接受陌生人提供的搭便车的事实。倾向于随性对待自己好感的女孩们，按自己的选择行事并没有犯罪，但她们必须意识到，这样做会让自己面临致命的危险。”安妮·玛丽·马基塔感到震惊。这篇文章不仅把悲剧的责任归咎于受害者，而且这些年轻女性并没有随性对待自己的好感，也没有像文章所暗示的那样在街上游荡。她们只是在过自己的生活。几起绑架案都发生在大白天，
while most of the women were waiting for public transport. Some were meeting friends, going to work, or trying to make it home in time for their curfews. To place the blame on them for the atrocities they endured made Ann Marie Makita feel physically sick. She detailed her experience of loss and grief in a book titled, It's a Long Way to Truro, providing an emotional insight into what she and her family went through during Julie's disappearance, and the subsequent murder investigation. Ann Marie's experience also inspired her to start an organisation called, The Victims of Crime Services, to provide support for victims and families whose lives had been
当时大多数女性正在等待公共交通。有些人在见朋友，去上班，或者试图在宵禁前赶回家。把她们所遭受的暴行的责任归咎于她们，让安妮·玛丽·马基塔感到一阵恶心。她在一部名为《去特鲁罗的路很长》的书里详细讲述了自己经历的失去和悲伤，为她和家人在朱莉失踪及随后的谋杀调查期间所经历的一切提供了情感上的洞察。安妮·玛丽的经历也激励她创办了一个名为“犯罪受害者服务”的组织，为那些因暴力犯罪而改变了生活的受害者和家庭提供支持。
changed due to a violent crime. By the early 1980s, the organisation had more than 1400 members, including Les and Kath Ratcliffe, whose 11-year-old daughter Joanne was abducted from the Adelaide Oval in 1973 and never seen again. Ann Marie became close with the Ratcliffe family, visiting Les on his deathbed as he prayed fruitlessly for answers about his daughter before tragically passing away from cancer. Through their shared experiences, Ann Marie also formed a strong bond with Judith Barnes, the mother of 17-year-old Alan Barnes, who was a victim in a string of murders committed by a group
到20世纪80年代初，该组织拥有1400多名会员，其中包括莱斯和凯斯·拉特克利夫，他们的11岁女儿乔安妮于1973年在阿德莱德椭圆球场被绑架，至今下落不明。安妮·玛丽与拉特克利夫家族关系密切，她曾在莱斯临终前探望他，当时他正徒劳地为寻找女儿的下落而祈祷，随后不幸死于癌症。通过共同的经历，安妮·玛丽还与朱迪思·巴恩斯建立了牢固的纽带，朱迪思是17岁少年阿兰·巴恩斯的母亲，阿兰是被称为“家庭”的团伙所犯下的一系列谋杀案中的受害者，正如《案卷》第166集所涵盖的那样。这两个女人都经历过每个父母最噩梦的场景，她们从彼此身上找到了慰藉，并在法庭听证会和审判期间互相支持。
dubbed The Family, as covered in episode 166 of Case File. Having both endured every parent's worst nightmare, the women found comfort in one another, and supported each other through court hearings and trials. In 1983, the body of 15-year-old Richard Colvin was discovered after he was abducted from the streets of North Adelaide. Richard was also a victim of The Family. His brutal murder had such a strong impact on the community that people demanded a return on the death penalty and called for a curfew on adolescents for their own protection. Despite everything Ann Marie Makita had gone through, she was vocally opposed to the idea of a curfew. She told reporters,
1983年，15岁少年理查德·科尔文在北阿德莱德街头被绑架后，其尸体被发现。理查德也是“家庭”团伙的受害者。他遭受的残忍谋杀对社区产生了如此强烈的冲击，以至于人们要求恢复死刑，并呼吁对青少年实施宵禁以保护他们自身安全。尽管安妮·玛丽·马基塔经历了这一切，但她公开反对宵禁的想法。她告诉记者：
grief, fear and anger are what produce all this talk about curfews for children, but clearly it is not the answer. You can't keep adolescent children in a cage. You have to prepare them to face the world alone. I don't know what the answer is, but it isn't capital punishment, vigilantes and curfews. It's much bigger than that. It's us as a community. We have to be more caring. Following the arrest of James Miller for the Truro murders, a young woman wrote a letter to the advertiser. In it, she complained about the level of detail the newspaper had gone into when Julie Makita's body was discovered, saying it was in poor taste and showed no consideration for the feelings of Julie's family. On the contrary, it was this letter that upset Julie's mother.
悲伤、恐惧和愤怒是所有这些关于儿童宵禁言论的产物，但显然这并不是答案。你不能把青春期的孩子关在笼子里。你必须让他们做好独自面对世界的准备。我不知道答案是什么，但绝不是死刑、私刑和宵禁。这比这要宏大得多。这是我们整个社区的事。我们必须更有爱心。在詹姆斯·米勒因特鲁罗谋杀案被捕后，一名年轻女子给《广告人报》写了一封信。信中，她抱怨了报纸在发现朱莉·马基塔尸体时所使用的细节程度，称这品味低下，且没有考虑到朱莉家人的感受。相反，正是这封信惹恼了朱莉的母亲。
Ann Marie didn't want Julie's death to be swept under the rug, but instead wanted people to know exactly what her daughter went through in the hopes it would raise awareness of the dangers that lurked in the shadows. In response to the letter, Ann Marie wrote an open message to the young women of Adelaide, wanting them to know that their sleepy city wasn't as safe as they thought. It read, I am sorry that the report of the finding of my daughter's body and the picture of the policeman carrying her offended you. But what would you have done? Do you want Julie to be just another statistic, hidden away in the paper, or perhaps not reported at all, so that nobody will be subjected to poor taste?
安妮·玛丽不想让朱莉的死被掩盖，而是希望人们确切地知道她的女儿经历了什么，以期提高人们对潜伏在阴暗角落里的危险的认识。作为对这封信的回应，安妮·玛丽给阿德莱德的年轻女性写了一封公开信，希望她们知道，她们这个安静的城市并不像她们想象的那样安全。信中写道：“我很抱歉，关于发现我女儿尸体的报道以及警察扛着她的照片冒犯了你们。但你们会怎么做呢？你们希望朱莉只成为另一个统计数字，被藏在报纸里，或者甚至根本不被报道，这样就不会有人受到低级趣味的困扰吗？”
Julie was a person, a girl very full of life, as were Veronica, Sylvia, Vicki, Connie, Tanya, and Deborah. They were real girls just like you, and they died just as you could die, not because they had hurt anyone or angered anyone, but because they were on the street at the wrong time. That is what I find heartless and distressing, the fact that they were killed, not the fact that a humane reporter wrote about the discovery of my daughter's body as if she were a real person. I know now that girls are dragged from the streets almost every night, or they are enticed into cars, and later left hurt and frightened, raped maybe, maybe even dead. This is not something unfortunate that happened two years ago, this is something that
朱莉是一个人，一个充满生机的女孩，维罗妮卡、西尔维娅、维基、康妮、坦娅和黛博拉也是如此。她们就像你们一样是真实的女孩，她们的死也正如你们可能会死一样，不是因为她们伤害了谁或惹恼了谁，而是因为她们在错误的时间上了街。这就是我觉得冷酷和痛苦的地方，是她们被杀害这件事，而不是一个充满人情味的记者像对待一个真正的人一样报道了我女儿尸体的发现。我现在知道，几乎每天晚上都有女孩从街上被强行拖走，或者被诱骗上车，随后受到伤害和惊吓，也许被强奸，甚至可能丧命。这不是两年前发生的什么不幸的事，这是
could happen tonight, tomorrow, to you. Every time you go out alone at night, you are at risk. Every time you get into a stranger's car, you put your life in his hands. I don't want you to be hurt or frightened for one moment. Every time I hear of a girl raped or injured, my daughter dies in my heart again. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
今晚、明天、随时可能发生在你身上的事。每次你独自在夜间外出时，你都身处危险之中。每次你坐上陌生人的车，你都是把自己的生命交托在他手中。我不希望你们有一刻受到伤害或惊吓。每当我听到有女孩被强奸或伤害，我的女儿就在我的心中再次死去。目前还没有针对这一集的评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。